you
and you can put the mics on which i did
not have mine on
but uh it's on now and uh for all to
know that it is streamed and so with
that though i'd like to get right into
the business
and we do have some folks here today
that um
will help us go through this bill it's a
very lengthy bill
20 pages in it
and uh during the hearing itself we
got the 30 000
foot high
view
uh now it's time to really delve into
uh
not just the intent we know intent is at
least i have pretty good understanding
where we're going we're trying to
establish a funding process here in the
state which supports uh all students
and all communities uh regardless of
their wealth
property values etc and so um i'd like
to uh invite um
those that are here today now we're
going to have some technical people
helping us with this going through it so
i see uh bill archer hartinger dick ames
uh i don't know if jay kahn is part of
that group or or
santa luna you are also on this
subcommittee
so with that i'd like to open up to the
floor and perhaps at this time uh before
we start i'll recognize uh represent
luna who is on the subcommittee
to
seeing that he is the prime sponsor of
this bill thank you great thank you very
much mr chair and members of the uh of
the subcommittee and uh
and uh uh
and i'd also like to uh before we get
started uh introduce some
uh colleagues who who uh we have worked
together to um uh to uh to put together
this um this bill house bill 1680
and uh there are also colleagues of ours
on the commission to study school
funding and so um uh so we have mary
heath um uh sitting back here senator
khan
um next to me uh uh representative dick
ames
uh sitting at the um
the desk
uh in front of the committee and
and bill artinger
an attorney
tax attorney and a former member of the
state legislature and
a member of the school funding
commission along with
you representative vlad
so just one thing a reminder for anybody
that's here that does not have a copy of
1680 they are available on the table to
your right to my left
go ahead right great thanks thanks very
much
rick and
in addition to copies of 1680 up on the
table there are also
a
a section by section analysis of the
bill which we're going to be
talking through
this morning
a memo
prepared by representative ames
on the statewide education property tax
reform that's contained in the bill as
well as a
memo prepared by attorney artinger and
they will be speaking to uh to both of
those as we as we go through things this
morning
as the chair noted back when the bill
was introduced a week and a half ago
it was late in the afternoon we did a we
introduced it from the 30 000 foot
view and i think the the objective today
is to uh is to go through this in
in detail
each of the 25 sections of the bill
and um and be able to uh to take
questions
from the uh
from the members of the subcommittee uh
as we're going along
and um
although i think neatly um groups of
these of these sections can sort of be
put into uh categories
like how do you develop a foundation
opportunity budget how do you fund these
budgets and then what is the uh what is
the tax impact so so we've sort of
organized our presentation to go through
the bill in that order it does go
chronologically
and um and i'll i'll start again with
with just a couple minutes to uh to to
talk about the bill in general and then
we'll we'll get right into it but um but
house bill 1680 is uh is really a uh a
complete reform on how we
both cost and define cost and fund and
adequate education for all students in
in new hampshire no matter where they
live
the first thing it does is it defines
constitutional adequacy in terms of
student performance and that's been a
thing that we've heard for years here in
the house education committee is what
are we doing about student performance
how can we increase student performance
how can we improve student performance
and that's that's a that's the
fundamental objective behind house bill
1680. uh the second thing it does is it
establishes a method to cost a
foundation opportunity budget to allow
the students in every school every
school district across the state
to um
to achieve a statewide outcome statewide
outcomes in new hampshire among the best
in the country it's been that way for
years
and
uh the concern is that it's just not
everywhere we're going to show that but
this
house bill 1680
is directed to rectifying that
it also does two
two specific things it separates the
costing function from the funding
function so
you know it costs
it costs more to educate a thousand kids
in manchester than it does a thousand
kids in bedford and um
but uh but how you go about funding that
might be different in manchester than it
is than it is in bedford or other
communities across the state so we
separate costs from funding
um and then um and then very important
in the uh in the bill
and uh and tied with it is um is a
meaningful property tax relief program
that is directed to low and middle uh
low and middle income uh homeowners
uh and um and is is
puts the puts the
the state dollars that are that are
associated with this program directs
those dollars to where they're needed
most as opposed to you know some sort of
blanket um
property tax reduction based on your zip
code it's directed based on need
um
the um uh the
house bill 1680 has both a transition
plan to ramp up the um
the funding of schools over a 10-year
period
it's important that that schools be able
to
to use those dollars
and make those make those incremental
improvements it can't happen it won't
happen all at once so it ramps in over a
10-year period of time and it also plot
it also includes transition grants
for uh for communities that
that you know i'll use the term hold
harmless but it's not stabilization and
it ramps down over a five-year period as
the um as the um as the foundation
budgets ramp up
and then finally and um and maybe one of
the most important things this bill does
is establish a clear and transparent
accountability
to make sure that school districts are
spending
these funds in a way that lead to to
student outcomes and like i said the
student outcomes are measurable and the
accountability provision has um has
support so that um that if a district is
is falling behind or is not making the
the um the strides that it needs to make
for their students that that the state
can come in and provide a little help
and assistance for them to get there so
that's again just the uh the 30 000 uh
foot flyover and and if the chair is
okay i'll sort of move over to the
to the section by section
and we can start um
22 page bill rick
yep starting on page one let's start
so
do you have a sheet that's going to
parallel going through the
you know that's this sheet okay you'll
so uh so thanks very much and i'll start
with with section one um section one uh
includes ten findings
that that largely stem from uh from the
work that was uh that was done um in the
school during the school funding
commission and uh and these findings
build on uh on each other
the um uh the first one um really says
that
that that
elementary and secondary in education in
new hampshire
should um
should
provide all students with the ability to
acquire knowledge and skills we've
talked about that in this committee the
importance not just knowledge it's
knowledge and skills
and it's done regardless of where
students live
so we're building on these opportunities
the uh the second one uh talks about an
integrated system of shared
responsibility between state and local
government to get students to a
statewide outcome and uh and and the
bill will be uh we'll be discussing that
but school districts
would then have the responsibility and
flexibility for implementing diverse
educational approaches to instruction
curriculum tailored to meet their
student needs we know that districts
across the state they're not all cookie
cutter they're not all the same
and it's important that uh that school
boards
have that ability to um to to uh to and
the flexibility to uh to meet their
student needs whether you're in coast
county or you're here in merrimack
county dave yeah i wonder if i could
interject absolutely at any time yeah
i just want to underscore this
particular
uh purpose that
is in uh
on page
guess it's page one
of the act
anyway the first part of the act
the second purpose
respecting the long traditional
community involvement
provide an integrated system of shared
responsibility i think that's a
fundamental concept it's present already
in the law
and we wanted to work
with that concept you'll find it
throughout this bill
that this is
not the state it's not the localities
it's an integrated system of shared
responsibility where the state has its
role and the
school districts have their role
thank you very much dick
and uh you know i should have pointed
that out right at the top too that as we
go through this bill uh we're also we'll
be we'll be talking about the um the
court decisions that uh obviously new
hampshire has been through decades of uh
of court decisions that have shaped the
uh the school funding policy that's in
place today
and uh and obviously we're uh we're
we're waiting on um
on uh to hear what the the the supreme
court sorry the superior court will do
with respect to the conval decision and
then obviously that'll probably go up to
the supreme court after that so uh so
there's a lot of moving parts to this
and um
and uh dave i i'd like to just if i
could just it's because this is a work
session we are working yeah we can
interact as well i'd like to follow up
to what uh representative ames just
mentioned referencing the shared
responsibility
if you have the statutes
in front of you which are
that we get here on the education
committee the very first statute
21n colon 1
references
exactly what you said
so it's the first statute of book it
basically says the general court finds
that the students parents general
citizenry local teachers and
administrators local governments local
school boards school administrative
units and state government have a joint
and shared responsibility for the
quality of education delivered through
the public education system in the state
of new hampshire
so it's pretty clear
good go ahead no thank you thank you
very much rick for uh for pointing that
out and that's that's what's what's
meant here uh we'll also be talking
about the shared responsibility in terms
of funding um and adequate education too
so we'll get to that
in uh in just a little bit um in roman
three uh long history what you were just
talking about mr chair and where where
voters
approve budgets you know across the
state and i think that's reflective
of why
new hampshire has such strong outcomes
statewide compared to other states
across the country uh it it it clearly
reflects the voters the voters at every
school district meeting that have the
have the ex priority and high
expectation for student outcomes in
districts and that's uh that's one of
the hallmarks behind new hampshire's uh
public uh school system
so
roman four
um
defying the com concept of an adequate
education in terms of outcome and
performance and uh and being able to tie
that in with um with accountab
accountability because the performance
is measurable and we'll be talking more
about that as we go through go through
the bill
the the data that um that
was developed during the um during the
funding commission
work
does indicate a strong correlation
between
poverty
and um and student outcomes
and
and probably mr chair
you you probably
recall some of these these bubble charts
from the from the school funding
commission work and this one in
particular is on page 27
and uh and where you uh where you take a
look at outcomes which currently based
on the data that's collected from the
department of education is performance
on standardized statewide
assessment tests
attendance rates and graduation rates
shows where
we're where shows that students in
school districts that have a a
high concentration of free and reduced
price lunch families so a lower
socioeconomic
capacity in those families have poorer
outcomes and um and and that's something
that uh in new hampshire we want to uh
to try to uh try to address with uh with
this legislation and uh and and really
close that opportunity gap for um for
all students no matter where they uh
where they live or what their
backgrounds are
the um uh roman
roman six um
uh again a strong relationship
correlation between poverty and total
spending and that's another
another graph that comes out of the
school funding commission's work and
when you take a look at new hampshire
it's a highly regressive trend
as
as poverty increases spending deep
spending decreases substantially and you
compare that to massachusetts which
which has uh has pushed that in the
opposite opposite direction so uh so so
you know recognizing the fact that it
costs more to educate a thousand kids in
manchester than it does a thousand kids
in bedford or a thousand kids in
hopkinton i'll just pick on
pick on my town in that case is that all
right sue
okay
let's see uh
wrapping into the final um the final few
um
uh findings and this is where we're
really where we've built now on on the
past findings
uh roman seven talks about cost
the opportu what is the cost
for every school district to educate
their students to a statewide outcome so
that's separating the cost from the
funding and that cost is is done on a
school district by school district basis
regardless of where um where where you
live
roman 8
is the funding um side of that that um
that
and again it goes back to the shared
responsibility
between the local government the local
school district and the and the state in
terms of being able to uh to make sure
that that funding is uh is adequate and
sufficient to uh to meet the foundation
opportunity budget where uh where some
towns we know across the state there's a
lot of communities that are working
super hard and just can't come close to
funding their budgets and this is
funding an adequate budget and this is
where the state comes in to make sure
that uh then it gets you there
um
let's see um
and then the the final um the final two
uh two findings in here
uh really uh really bring it all
together um where um where adequacy is
framed in terms of targeted outcomes
that facilitate a system public school
funding funding from the state state
sources to the communities with the
greatest need
to deliver a constitutionally adequate
education regardless of where the
student lives so providing that um that
that
the gas where it's needed to make sure
that um uh that every school district
has access to the resources they need
and then uh the final uh finding here um
is um is tied to what we'll be talking
about it's in the bill but uh but we
ramp up the um the foundation
opportunity plan and we ramp uh we have
a transition grant that ramps down
uh to make sure that uh that we don't
shock the system either way that we
don't um uh shock the system with
foundation opportunity budgets that um
that that give
the the um uh system admin the the
district administration
the ability to uh to deploy those funds
in an effective and efficient manner and
we don't shock the system in terms of um
uh sudden changes to uh to tax rates
and uh
and we think we've got a uh a good
proposal to address both those things so
um
uh happy to take any questions on on the
findings but next up senator khan is
going to
talk uh talk us through section two of
the bill
which um which is really um you know
jay's got uh you know big shoulders here
because um this is um this is really the
crux of um of the um of the of the
bill's um
um
uh body where it uh really defines and
quantifies the state's obligations
thank you david uh
chairman uh good to
see just my first house
during this session
uh
i think this is on
so let me uh
i will talk about cost
uh
it's the part of the study that
i spent the most time on
and
uh
we reviewed
a number of
costs education costs analyses that have
since the original claremont
lawsuit
and uh
the the one that uh stands out for all
of us is the 2008
uh study
uh that is the joint legislative
oversight committee on costing an
adequate education
it's dated february of
2008.
it's now 14 years old
it's an appropriate time to come back
and take a look
what did what were the recommendations
what did we implement uh what did we not
implement
uh
and uh is it getting us to where we need
to be
um
so in 2008 there was a strong
emphasis in that report
to arrive at a universal cost per
student that is the primary emphasis in
this report
and it's it's intended to be an
accounting
of
education costs
uh and that's what it does and and
you're familiar with it because we've
used it
uh for
our biennial budgeting for the last 14
years
and and what it is largely based on uh i
mean if you take the the total array of
student costs of the cost of a public
education in the state
the 3.3 billion dollars that's spent
between state and local resources
um
you you you know that
uh
60 percent to two-thirds of total cost
is instruction
and so
uh when it rolls up the
what is the accounting for instruction
uh it's based on a class size for k-2
of 25 students to one instructor
and for grades three through 12 at 30
and when you look at the department of
education's data
you'll find that the average
across the state
and
you won't find a single district that
has an average of 25
so
one
the basic metric is is way off
uh
the second observation is uh that
the second cost driver is
uh
salaries and benefits for teachers
well the teacher cost is based on a
beginning teacher credential if you
think to
our statutes about
how teachers are credentialized
beginning teacher is anywhere between
zero and three years you've got to have
three years experience
and two positive evaluations to become
an experienced teacher
so we peg it
at the third year
of a beginning teacher
and
so it that that's deceptive because
that's certainly not the average cost of
an instructor
and the second is that the benefits are
pegged at 33 percent of the salary
so
we had testimony to the commission from
school business officers that said nope
uh it's really 58
is the benefit cost
so we've got the three primary drivers
on two thirds of the cost uh
pegged at
numbers that
just don't
don't jive and that's why we probably
have lawsuits that perpetuate to this
day
the
the other thing to recognize is that the
universal cost that was recommended in
is 3400
let me get this right 34
156 dollars per pupil
and what we have in the budget is
six dollars
uh the point being
in fourteen years that total
cost that universal cost has moved ten
percent
uh which is
another defying
and then the third thing to take into
account is uh
the differentiated costs
because one of the things that the 2008
study did is it benchmarked against
national uh variables that where other
states were using
and employed some pretty good ideas
about english learning students
english language learning students being
a more expensive
investment
to bring that student up to
an adequacy adequate level
it it recognizes uh special needs of
students
special education needs
the uh economically
uh
economic differences poverty index uh of
students so these are things that are
brought into the formula we do have
differentiated ratios we just didn't
implement them at the levels that were
recommended
in a for instance special education was
recommended as a two-tiered
cost
one that recognized in in-district
placement and one that recognized an
out-of-district placement
we we don't do that
uh in our formula
we peg it at the lowest number that we
could
which is the lower tier as recommended
in the 2008 study
um
so
again we we just we don't have uh we
didn't implement it and that was uh iris
esther brooks
be moaning
uh as a
2008 commissioner uh as she participated
in our uh 2020 study
uh
so those are the characteristics
well i know we'll get back to it yep uh
when senator estabrook
and company
put this together back in 2008
um when we were looking at the special
ed the tearing you said we we didn't get
to the two-tiered
uh i understand we don't have weighted
uh formula
based because due to the amount of time
or an amount of service
the type of service that an individual
might require but we do didn't we have
basically two tiers in fact we had the
the amount that stated within
differentiated aid
but we had set aside another area
statute cap aid
which provided the additional amount for
the student which was being serviced
oftentimes either out of district or out
of state
so i guess
we we had two tiers
of a sort
but we did not tier the first category
at all
thank you
you are correct
chairman land uh
but let me give you the
another chunk that'll
you probably are going to be surprised
the
the self-contained
uh or in building special education uh
was the higher tier
in the 2008 study so it wasn't the out
of district as you say that has a
categorical aid element
and a different basis on how that's
distributed
it's the self-contained that was
supposed to be reimbursed at three
thousand six hundred and ten
dollars uh
you know we're at two thousand dollars
today
so and and that's gone up you know kind
of significantly in the last two years
so uh yeah we never never got the 3600
per in district
self-contained
special education student
okay let's go let's go on with where
you're going i i perhaps we can come
back and we'll discuss all these points
which been brought up a little bit more
in detail
this is certainly an area where there's
going to be a lot of discussion
uh as well it can be yeah uh
and i i'll not get diverted i'll not
take that that side that side that's
right let's let's keep marching here
um
so
uh
as david said uh you know what so what's
the alternative
uh if
if what we've been working with is not
uh getting us to the outcomes that we
desire
what is the method to get us there and
and so
uh using an outcome-based
definition which
picking it up from state statutes in
193e
we developed three
measures
one is graduation rates
another it's attendance rates and the
third is the standardized test scores
three through eight plus uh the
sophomore year in high school
uh we use ten years worth of data so
it's not like we fixed on a certain
point in time we were able i mean that's
a bunch of school districts
and their 10-year performance levels
uh
working into the data
and and we used regression modeling and
the thing about regression modeling is
that you're aiming towards averages
right
and deviations from the averages ought
to create some deviation in
how much we reimburse so if we know what
the statewide average is
in all those metrics which as david said
our metrics are high
in overall performance
then we know how much each district has
of students
that deviate or exceed
the statewide average
and that becomes a basis for the cost
and and
no surprise
those same metrics that
were used in the 2008 formula until
today
for differentiated aid still hold up
they still make a difference and they
define the difference in student outcome
performance
in every school district across the
state
so
english learning poverty special
education needs are those unique student
characteristics in each district that
need to be accounted for
and we we can tell by the state average
how much
each of those
student characteristics cost
to get to a state average
we also know that the districts have
certain characteristics that make a
difference
a
small district
you might raise the question of that and
chairman you might remember your your
question about that is that a district
small by choice
or is this small by regional
circumstance we didn't differentiate on
that
but we did recognize that small
matters and that it's higher cost as you
spread it across the student we also
recognized that contrary to the 2008
study
that
it's not the elementary education level
that has a higher cost
its middle school has the highest cost
and then high school has a higher cost
than elementary school
and
so we were able statistically to verify
that
and you'll see that that's wrapped into
the school characteristics that
require
an additional
funding
costing
element um
so
when it comes to uh section
uh
three in the study
you'll find a series of ratios that
relate both to student
and to
district characteristics
all aimed
at trying to bring
each district
the resources necessary to educate the
student population that they have
unique to that school
in that district and that town
so that's the
basis of the costing study
at a high level
and
we need any q a glad to turn to that but
uh if there's
a progression here i know it it moves to
another part of the bill that i'm not
prepared to go into
thank you
thank you mr chair and i'm sorry i don't
have my book with me and i'm really not
that familiar in your model of this
costing are the different the three
different areas weighted differently
like like does um attendance rate count
more than state assessment rate or how
does that work
they're melded together
and produce what's called in the study a
z score
are then melded together into a single
score
and and that's how
we're able to
consistently apply this in a fairly
simple manner
so let's say
district a has a wonderful attendance
rate
fantastic
[Music]
graduation rate but low state assessment
rates
how each one it's just a plus b plus c
divided by three and that's your score
or um how does that work um actually uh
test scores relate
account for about
85 to 90 percent of the overall weight
and that's because those other two
weights are explained by the test scores
meaning sorry
a district
that has
a low attendance rate
or a low graduation rate also has low
test scores
so
um
but but it but it it it does vary
it does vary and you're right
they do vary and that's why the three
measures are appropriate to to be
considered not to get stuck on a single
measure
but to recognize that all three of these
are factors that
contribute to the outcomes
go ahead
so were any other factors considered
besides those three
i get really nervous when everything is
based on ones
85 percent of it is based on a
standardized test score and that really
makes me nervous
i was comfortable with
having it be a little bit differently
weighted but it still i think puts a
disadvantage
on some districts and i'm wondering
if anything else was considered like the
number of kids who go on to grad
colleges and graduate schools and the
number of people who go into the
military and what professions they
choose and what degrees they earn
afterwards and those kinds of things
which are also indicators of a school's
quality i would think
right
i i
this whole formula there's a
a lot to it i understand that and i've
been through it with the commission
but one of the areas which
i'm still foggy on
is that
i
we're driving to try to find out what it
costs
to have a student in this state all
students
get to that performance outcome that
we're looking to achieve
or have
and
when we come down to special services
special education there's a certain
percentage of that total amount which is
going to be allocated out my concern is
then
when we're going to fund all special ed
kids
at the same weighted amount that kind of
rings a bell in my head saying that's
not true we have some kids which are a
half hour a week other kids that are
full time with supported staff and
services which are very costly
this is a
critical concern to me that we when
we're when we're looking at
whatever that
amount might be if it's four point
something times what the
the base cost is
then then is that for all kids or are
there different weights
associated with a child that has a
learning disability versus that that has
a
severe emotional mental
uh handicap in the area that that's
so
uh
we were unable to get that information
from the department
uh
and it's because in smaller districts
uh it becomes a an identifying
you can identify and associate by grade
level
uh
particular students in that school
so
we were unable to
to get that granular a level of
information i will say as i prepared
last night and i was looking for more
information about student costs
we do have some student costs i mean
about special education at district
levels in the doe 25
and it is
20 000 more
per special education student
and that's an average
but that's what it is
and uh
you know when we were able to attribute
the costs for different student
variables
the base cost wound up at six thousand
the total cost was seventeen thousand
dollars a student
the base cost was six thousand dollars
meaning we could explain all the other
outcome differences with all the other
costs
uh
and
special education
uh
there you go it's on average twenty
thousand dollars the ratio here is a
four four time four x
uh number and and it pans out
uh that that is the extra that stupid
school districts are reporting for a
special education student and i i get it
chairman
if we had the data
you might be able to differentiate it
but we know that there are 30 000 30 000
ieps in the state and
they're costing significantly in the
districts that have a higher
percentage of i know it'd be very
difficult senator to break
a weighted amount
out
if we're going to do it the way some
states do do that they have that
information provided to the department
we do have the department knowledgeable
of the the types of handicapping
conditions we can get that total
information that is available it's on
the web
however
within those categories
there's a whole lot of of difference i i
think that this is one area
that
we need to as legislators to drive home
to department of education
we need the information
to really round this thing out properly
and hopefully that might be one of the
expectations that we can you know put
down the side as
does the doe
really reflect
what we're looking for as far as the
content of an adequate does the special
information we have here having to rely
upon
i'd like to delve and dig into it a
little bit more with the department and
it's time maybe that we have them start
looking at that doe 25 form and revising
it to give us the more specific i
somewhere along the way we're going to
have to get a little bit more down in
um so
go ahead yep yep mr chair uh later on in
the bill there's a whole section on data
collection where where where the bill
um uh suggests uh additional pieces of
data that the department could collect
and that uh could go into um to later
revisions of of
developing um you know measuring uh
student outcomes by district and uh and
also factoring into the um
a uh you know the funding or i'm sorry
the costing formula that um uh that this
used but but currently we're using 10
years of department data that that were
available to the to the commission and
uh like senator khan said
the the detailed breakdown in special
education categories was only available
for one year
and um and uh and and not broken out in
um in in prior years
but uh but i think what's uh what's
what's very clear though is um is you
know if the um if a future funding i'm
sorry a future costing formula
was was going to leverage that that
additional granularity in special
education categories that the department
could in fact do that because they do
have that information
there there is some information that we
could take and tear apart
they do list all those handicapped
conditions and the number of students
per district that are
associated with that type of a handicap
right it's just not publicly available
data well we got numbers we got numbers
we don't have the ieps if you look on
the web those numbers that we have in
the state are there we've gone way back
you can go back a good 10 15 years and
collect that information it is there but
we don't know
when you look at for example a child
that has a learning disability it
doesn't give us any information we could
get the maybe the
i don't even think we could find the
average cost of the learning disability
handicap first the the average cost of
another handicap
because there is such a variance within
these handicaps at the cost and within
an individual
uh based upon the iep there's a huge
variance as well
sometimes in years ago we used to be
able to count a kid as being monitored
um
when they're coming out of that iep that
they've had we don't have that condition
anymore but if we'd had it we would be
funding a monitored child that's in the
classroom and not really receiving any
help now because they're on our way
they're exiting the iep program
and that would have been funded a huge
amount of money and uh i don't want to
see administrators chasing this money
seeing that it provides a real huge hunk
of dollar
you know if you take your six thousand
dollars multiplied by four
that's a lot of money right right so
just sort of getting us back
um no and and
i absolutely appreciate that um but just
um getting us back to the bill so that
we can go through going through the
sections yeah the uh what uh what center
khan's talking about here is um is we
have that information from the doe 25s
to you know the granularity that it that
that exists today
and um and we know for every school
district with
a certain with with uh with a student
population with certain characteristics
and and certain district characteristics
like how many students are in elementary
how many students in middle how many
students are in high school
and the budgets that are spent the money
that is spent in each of those
elementary middle and and high school
and we also know the the outcome data
for uh for each of these districts so
it's it's using that mass of information
for every district in the um in the
state
each of the districts specific outcomes
each of the districts specific student
and uh and school characteristics that
we can then calculate and this is what
uh senator kahn's talking about in
section three
then calculate what a um what a budget
would be or would would
predict what a budget should be
in order for
the outcome in any district to be um to
be a a statewide average so what would
it be what would a budget in manchester
need to be so that the average student
in manchester was performing at a
statewide average
as opposed to the fifth percentile right
now what would the budget in hopkinton
need to be
for the average student at hopkinton to
perform at a statewide average as
opposed to the 82nd percentile as uh as
is right now so state average would be
the 50th percentile so so some districts
would would see a foundation opportunity
budget less than what they're currently
spending some districts would see a
foundation opportunity budget more than
what they're current uh currently
spending in order so that the average
student in those districts is performing
at a state level i i understand all that
representative and
just take an example of waterville
valley what's happened in the last year
their economy of scale we talked about
that a little bit uh previously here
outside of school district etc and and
we know that it costs more to run a
school with fewer students look at
what's happened there by increasing by
70 students up there the cost per pupil
has gone down significantly
that's economy of scale
so and
so i'm jumping off a little bit i'm
sorry uh let's let's keep going with the
conversation here uh certainly special
services is going to be a uh
a larger discussion as we get going here
in in this whole thing um mr chair yes i
just want to i i i'm hoping this is
where you have there um thank you for
letting me participate in this work
session i really appreciate it just to
sum up
senator khan
went through sections two
three
and four
of the bill with his remarks that's on
page two
page three
oh well we haven't gone through all
pages
i haven't touched it yet but let me just
in terms of the concept i just want to
take a step back
and i am kind of from the legal side of
things which education funding has been
a
legal issue that has plagued our state
for
decades now
that what section two does
is define
adequate education
as the state-wide
average so there's the target that's in
terms of outcomes
what section three does
is determine
the value
of achieving
that adequacy definition
in each district it differs by district
because of the reasons
representative luna said and then what
section four does
is provide
an easy way
to translate in terms of non-complicated
data analysis
which is very similar to the way the
state has done it in the past
of of using weightings of data that is
available and representative not just
outcome data this is other data like
free and reduced launch stuff that we're
familiar with and it uses that data
to determine
what amount
is necessary in each district to allow
it to achieve the definition of an
adequate education from a court
perspective
this is one of the first bills
that is so clear
on how we're achieving the required
constitutional effort using
the shared governance
that representative aims talked about
between representative land state and
local government maintaining that
balance which as we all know the
evidence is clear new hampshire's common
public school system k through 12 is
producing right now
high quality outcomes
for on average so our goal is with this
structure defining educa adequate
education in terms of a target
performance level
costing what it costs to get there to
enable a district to get there given
their unique circumstances what we're
trying to do is address
opportunity gaps
where in the state we have opportunity
gaps
the state side of the partnership will
lay in
more support
to help that district close the gap for
its students between the target and
where it is now that's what sections two
three and four
do as a matter of
concept and it lays it out almost in a
step-by-step way
every 10 years
you've got to recalculate
using new data
at least every ten years
where the gap is what that means
is that for the first time
rather than the current system which is
based on cost you could spend
you know fifty dollars on computers in
one district and fifty dollars in
computers on another district
and get completely different performance
levels depending on the unique
attributes of those districts what this
does is actually set out data
every ten years at least that says
is that district with all its unique
attributes achieving
the goal of adequacy that is determined
by this legislature and so i just wanted
to take a step back from
the details and the weeds
are the most important always it is
but you've got to start with the
concepts in a sense and in two three and
four
just bang
bang you know what is the definition
it is not in terms of costs or dollars
it's in terms of a goal
an outcome because what do parents care
about
they don't care about how much money
a school is paying for a library
they care whether their child is getting
a good outcome and being prepared for
the world
and so this bill is more aligned with
that
today we're able to have more data than
we had 20 years ago which allows us to
make the shift at this time and as a
member of the commission which chairman
ladd was on and the others here what was
magical is to hear from a national
expert for the first time in new
hampshire
national experts say that this data
allows
for a methodology that really truly
focuses on
results
and results is what we all focus on i'm
sorry representative i just wanted to
take that step because the details are
sometimes confusing
but the goals are clear thank you
okay we're not at 30 000 feet we're down
about 25 000 feet now get us lower
represent luno
thank you very much mr chair to um uh
let's let's all just sort of turn to
page four because i think that's where
um where you'll you'll recognize some
similarities as bill larger
was speaking to similarity between
what's in the bill and what's in in
current statute and so
section section four
basically re-codifies um 198 colon 40 a
which is what determines the cost of
inadequate education so as as bill laid
out
adequate education is based on
performance based on outcomes based on
results
the next session
how do you cost that out and then this
section section four
going on to page four how do you easily
develop a formula to be able to
determine what that cost
for a for a um uh for an average student
in every district to to have a statewide
outcome
and um and these these
in this case they are called weights but
um in another terminology call them
differentiated aid factors which is what
we have in the uh in the current statute
but
through the analysis that was done in in
section three
um you can um you can you can
you can scientif you can derive
what uh what the weights are and um and
specifically for um for a a
student that uh that is that that gets
free and reduced price lunch
it would be 1.49
times the base
remember the base is 6 500 that's online
30 on page on page four 6501
so
so the way you build up this cost of an
adequate education
for um
for a school district to educate their
students to a statewide outcome
it starts with the um the enrollment
data uh in this case it's adma and i
think we are moving towards admr um as
nate and mark have have talked with us
so you know these are things that
that need to be need to be done but it's
the enrollment times the base
plus
the
number of students that are in free and
reduced price lunch times the base
times
the weighting factor of 1.49
same with special education number of
students with in special education times
the base
times 4.29 and that gets to what senator
khan was was talking about
from the uh you know from the earlier
data the cost of special education
and then and then on for english
language learners it's 2.2 is the factor
and then enrollment
total enrollment in a school district
and there's factors
going from small schools which would
have a factor of 1.08 to larger schools
0.57.43
0.24
those are all uh in here
and um
and then um
enrollment in um and actually the
enrollment
the uh uh
what i was just reading from here is
right out of the commission report those
are specific points at um
at enrollment levels like 200 students
600 students 1200 students
and
the the bill actually uses a smoothing
factor
you know sort of a cliff effect when
you're going from 200 students to 201
students
you know you lose you you would lose
that that funding so it smooths that out
um and then and then factors that also
include uh
um waiting for the for middle grades uh
1.42 and high school at 0.42
um
so so
so
these factors when taken all together
are are really differentiated aid
you know categories like what we have in
in present law
and and provide the department
the ability to annually calculate what
what the cost for
for a foundation opportunity budget for
school district to educate all of its
students to a statewide outcome
would be much the way it calculates the
are there any questions of
representative luna or members of that
team that are here right now
yes represent like us
thank you
how did you come up kind of briefly how
did you come up with the particular
numbers
that you did
so so thanks for the question
representative lakis um that's what uh
senator khan was referring to the
regression analysis
and in this case it would be called a
multi-variant regression analysis where
you take a look at the the um the costs
in every district the costs that are
broken down in the doe 25 and the
results the student performance outcome
that you get in them in that district
and you you you basically
um draw a line through the um
through through
through
every district in the state and you you
do this not not physically drawing a
line but uh but but through uh through a
multivariate regression analysis and it
basically associates
the amount of each of those budgets
um that that is associated with let's
say free and reduced price lunch
enrollment or special education number
students in special education or the
number of english language learners and
it tries to find or i should say it
finds the best fit line that reduces the
error
because not every district is going to
spend exactly the same dollars on on
special education students or exactly
the same have the same costs for free
and reduce reduced price lunch student
or an ell student every district is
going to be a little bit different
but when you take a look at all those
districts across the state you can
actually find a best fit line that that
shows well on average this is what the
cost is
uh the the cost impact is for
um uh
you know for
in a budget for every free and reduced
price launch student for every english
language learner for every special
education and then for the the factors
that um that pertain to
district characteristics like school
size middle school and high school
so so
that's i'm you know i'm sorry it's sort
of like a
long-winded geeky you know answer on on
how you go about calculating it but but
it is called a
regression you know a multivariate
regression analysis
and uh
we have uh we actually have um a full
throated briefs
that were prepared by the uh by our
research team who uh who performed that
and would be happy to uh to email you
the links um uh to those
thank you so those are based on current
spending as
correct based on fy 19 okay that's yeah
thank you yeah fy 19 doe 25s
okay let's keep rolling
so um so that sort of takes us through
section four which on page four and and
goes to the top of page five and um
and we've sort of um
i think uh bill looks like he has uh
had to maybe jump out and take a call
but we're on to section five
and um
and uh bill was going to talk to that
but i'm happy to uh uh to to introduce
it so
everything we've talked about so far so
far
gets us to a cost
a budget to get a district to a to a
statewide outcome now we're talking
about the funding side of
of this argument of this plan
and um and
the um
uh
the first thing that that i think needs
to be needs to be explained here
is that um
and this is really sort of it's talked
about in in roman four
uh down on begins on line 28 on page
five
and uh and while while the foundation
opportunity budget for every district
has been has been calculated in in
section four
this
house bill 1680 looks at
the way it's drafted here is eight years
but we're really looking at a ten year
phase in of this um of this foundation
opportunity plan so i'll hand it over to
bill
thank you thank you very much and again
i apologize i
have some issues with my elderly parents
in cornish new hampshire where i was a
representative and i was just i had to
step out for a minute so thank you very
much for
letting me do that
so section five on page five
this is the almost the easiest part of
the bill
it's simple math
it says after you've defined and what an
adequate education is
after you've determined
what the value of that adequate
education is
in every district based on the
district's circumstances by getting a
foundation
opportunity budget that's the amount of
money
that this methodology predicts is the
amount they need to spend
to achieve the statistical the outcome
goal that is our definition
what you have that foundation
opportunity budget how do you get from
foundation opportunity budget
to what we all care about which is the
state budget grant that each district
gets
take the foundation opportunity budget
which may be different by district
subtract from it
an amount called the minimum local
contribution
minimum local contribution remember
representative ames focusing on the
finding partnership between
state government and local government
all integrated to achieve a goal
better outcomes for our students
what you do is the minimum local
contribution
is an amount that every district is
required
to put on the table
towards
local public education k-12 that you
know the common school that their kids
are that they're required to fund
what is that amount we got to determine
an amount
the minimum local contribution
is
five dollars per thousand
times
the
valuation of their tax base so it's
nothing tricky
local communities have been determining
things in terms of their local property
tax base which is the only tax base that
new hampshire state government
has granted power to local communities
to raise dollars to fund a minimum
contribution like this so
foundation opportunity budget let's
assume for a community
it is
uh a million dollars
minus
the minimum local contribution let's
assume five dollars per thousand let's
just assume right now 500 000.
so you take
the million
minus the 500 000
what's the balance 500 000 and then you
multiply it by two percentages in this
formula
one is an efficiency percentage
why did we choose that because
there's always a little bit and i'm
going to ask dave luno to talk about
this a little bit more there's always a
little bit
of differential between the perfect goal
of statewide average
and
some
various components that would say let's
make it 95
then you have to multiply it by another
percentage so we've got
the million minus the 500 000 equals 500
000 times the 95 percent
then we get to multiply by the
transition percentage representative
luno already said the reason we're
transitioning this
is not to shock any system one of the
failures over my years of working on ed
funding and i've worked on it since i've
for
for decades since 1993
with various uh elected officials the
is that we're always
not
we're always jumping a whole system in
place and then there's stabilization aid
or there's whole harmless grants it's
very confusing this is a nice
smooth glide path
the bill
will need an amendment
and representative luna was referred to
that it is a goal of of this group
that came out of the commission is a
10-year flight plan a glide path so that
you would start
in the 70 range
and you would ultimately get up to 100
so at the end of the 10-year period
there would be no more reduction
as you're phasing in this grant level
um for a community
like manchester which has as i think we
can all recognize has some of the
greatest challenges
of any community in terms of
just attributes like special ed like
poverty like um
you know
size of district and things like that
it's got some challenges
they would see an increase
in their grant level
other communities so would clermont
where i i went to high school at stevens
many many years ago
other communities
would not see an increase in their grant
and we'll get to that there is
protection in this 10-year plan
for those communities but basically when
you take section five
from line eight on page five
all the way down through
to the on page six to section six
it is a simple
math
what's my grant it's your foundation
budget minus your minimum local
contribution
times your percentages equals your grant
who determines it doe does just the same
way they do now
when do they report it
similar time frames for reporting how do
communities count on it
in when they're preparing their budget
because it is clearly in the law it is
simple math they know what it's going to
be under section 4 and section 3.
thank you for that summary of section 5.
okay questions on
section 5 represent porter
thank you mr chair i want to make sure i
understand this now so currently
district a is getting a million dollars
from the state
there's a possibility that the end
that the grant the opportunity grant
here would be more than that at some for
some districts
and less than that for other
so so if it's a district it's getting a
million dollars now in the future it
might get significantly more because of
the um
formula used to determine how much it
costs to get their kids to the to the
goal
other districts might get significantly
less than what they're getting now
because
their kids are above the goal already
is that what is that how this is
essentially
is it
in a concept
it works that way but
under the structure of this bill
because of section um the upcoming
section yeah
there is a transition or hold harmless
grant right that means if you were a
district like let's say for example
hanover
which has
you know is getting the same amount of
money per pupil now that claremont gets
yeah yeah
they would get a lower grant level
but it would be they get compensated for
a period of time by the whole harmless
grant that's in there so in the first
year of the operation they see zero
decrease right in their ground but
eventually
over the course of the 10 years
their amount of money coming from the
state would be
less at the end of 10 years than it is
currently in some cases that could be
the case but it's important
representative porter to recognize that
there's two things going on here that
transition percentage is going from the
70 percent area to a hundred
there's going to be communities that
would experience in the first year
a lower grant but they're held harmless
by the old harmless grant by the time
they reach the end of the
the 10-year phase in
they have higher grant levels than what
they had in the in the base year okay so
can i have a follow-up
so the the communities now that are
collecting maybe this is mixing apples
and oranges but
i kind of how my brain is this morning
i'm kind of a fruit salad
um
they're making me
hungry um
so we have some communities in the state
who collect we talk about the swept
checks i don't know if we're getting it
but they collect more swept tax than the
state owes them yes
and they keep it
and i haven't gotten to the end of the
bill yet so maybe the answer will be
there under this plan
will they be held harmless you
foreshadowed uh a subsequent
presentation because it is in the bill
may i defer on your question until you
get there thank you very much for that
question
so um and
looking at the londonderry case um
is how is this
scheme going to meet constitutionality
of of you know providing the amount of
money for adequacy to every child this
may i answer and because that that will
be a question which is going to pile on
us i think that that question underlies
and plagues
every discussion of education funding
this state has had
since 1997.
i
you're absolutely right to ask it and
every proposal
whether it's a change of the current
system or whether it's this more
fundamentally what i believe is a
fundamentally sound system
is going to asset here's what i think
the answer is
this bill
satisfies the requirements of all the
claremont cases including claremont ii
londonderry the king plan case which i
presented to the supreme court uh back
in 99 uh it satisfies it in my view as
one person
other lawyers other people may have
different views here's why i think it
satisfies it
the
claremont cases say that the state
legislature
has
substantial authority
to provide a constitutionally adequate
public education for every child in the
state
but they cannot shirk that duty they
must take steps to do it
this bill
is a completely integrated system
that establishes a common integrated
goal the foundation opportunity budget
with a definition of adequacy that is
about
outcomes
which many cases representative ladd
that the court has written
talk about that the legislature has
broad discretion of doing this
um
in in what happens is the working of the
state grant
and the minimum local contribution
together
make sure that every community is
required
to put together a system
that will achieve that outcome goal
through
at least
the combination of their foundation
opportunity grant and their minimal
local contribution
there will be some
who will argue
that the minimum local contribution
component
doesn't pass
muster
because it is using
a local property tax resource to meet
i
i and there will be some towns
all we're trying to get to is the
foundation opportunity budget under this
system there will be some towns
that their property tax base is
sufficient that they can fund their
appropriation requirement the minimum
local contribution
through their local base and they don't
need a grant to get there
some will argue
that that's using local property taxes
to fund public education
this court has never been presented
with a plan that is so integrated
that is so well balanced to focus on
one key definition for every community
and the court this court has said
is never said
that you can't have
local property taxes used to fund public
education never
has said that it's never said
that the local government units that
local control mean nothing anymore they
said the opposite
this program
balances the need for
continue i believe
local
investment of local communities through
local government is one of the driving
reasons that new hampshire
produces high quality outcomes from its
current common public school system and
this bill preserves it and i think if we
make the right case
to the supreme court they will focus on
the language that they've said where the
legislature is the leader in terms of
determining the policy here and they
will ultimately
support this kind of integrated proposal
in contrast i don't the court's going to
be hard-pressed
to support something on the current cost
system
where you know someone says it's three
thousand seven hundred nine dollars per
pupil
and everywhere in hanover as in
claremont
i think the court sees that as being
less reasonable less rational and but
that's a case that's pending right now
that's in trial that's the conval case
but on this bill representative ad
i think that this could withstand muster
because it's an integrated plan to hit a
foundation opportunity budget through a
partnership of local uh appropriation
and state appropriation thank you
were you going to say something then i
know that represent porter has a comment
or a question i always welcome
representative porter's questions
you'll be sorry representative that you
said that um
i i might be jumping ahead again
if a community wants to spend more
they can raise their taxes to do so i
mean if if this says we need
you guys need a million dollars to run
your schools and they say no we want a
million five we can raise our taxes to
absolutely i'll respond
okay it's in it's in the bill
okay and and is there is there not a
clause in the in the constitution
um that requires that it be
what we give to it has to be equal
across
i mean
i my understanding was
at one point
that the reason that the formula came up
that we have now came up was because
every child
has to get the same
has to be equal for every child i think
it's uh different that the equality
relates to the opportunity
the opportunity to be educated to have a
good education or the phrase used in new
hampshire is an adequate education
and uh what what it takes to provide
that is a different question and this
this bill as you've heard
uh looks very closely at a bunch of
variables and
comes down on the
place where it's different from district
i just wanted to uh just say
support what
bill artinger said in terms of
constitutionality
i think
the new hampshire supreme court has
never been presented
with a situation
where
the
irregularity the
high variability
of
local
tax rates
as it related to
funding of schools
had some rationality to it
this bill tries to put it all together
us when we're talking about that
adequate education level
in a rational way
using waiting and so forth
and then gets to a funding
formula that also
um is a sensible reasonable way of
of putting this together so
the the entirety of the bill
is what this the court will look at in
the context
that the court that the bill seeks to
create
and i think there's a very good chance
a a high probability that it will be
supported
they have used the court has used
language in the past
that gives one pause if you look at the
language
in those cases but those cases had a
context that was very different from the
one that we will be presenting so
i've come down i've thought long and
hard about this as we've sat through
endless along with you
representative led
endless commission meetings
and i've learned a lot uh it's been a a
good experience
um and it's enormously complicated
uh but i think uh
the court too will learn and and and uh
and support this if this is where we
come out
okay thank you thank you very much i'd
like to move ahead if we can
um we're we're just getting a lot of
this bill here and there's a lot of
discussion that we will have i'm sure
that's
unfortunately we don't have a lot of
time but so that we got to keep moving
here
so can you walk us through some of the
additional points absolutely let me just
tell you where we're say we're remarking
where we're at right now we have gone
through the heaviest part of
of this of this bill and i think we can
start to pick up some speed as we go
through the remaining side i'm sure
people would love to talk about swept so
well we're going to be getting into that
very shortly but but let me just hand it
back over to bill to uh to take us
through um uh section six sec i'm sorry
section six on page six
uh which um which i think he's spoken to
a lot of it right now i'm not going to
drag it out representative because we
kind of talked about
the minimum local contribution part
and we're going to talk about
representative porter's question about
swept comes up just a moment
the piece in section 6 that i'd like to
focus on additionally is on page 7
at
line 4
through line 32.
this is the transition grant
component so
if you are a community
where it has your sees your foundation
opportunity grant
being less
than a base year which in this bill is
fiscal year 2023 but in an amendment
that is being prepared by representative
luno and team
it may be a different year and i think
you should confirm that
uh that what will happen is
in the first year you get a hundred
percent of the difference
and then that phase is down in other
words it's saying to the local school
district
you know
we're
for example i'm not don't want to pick
on hanover but it's right near claremont
we used to play on basketball and stuff
like that so it you know in that case
says to hanover
we're going to focus our priority a
little bit more
on districts that have greater need
to achieve and close that opportunity
gap because children and this is mel
miller's representative milor's thing
children in claremont even if i live in
concord
are my children when i'm in new
hampshire
and so we're going to focus on claremont
but in the first year
don't worry we'll hold you harmless in
this bill and and i just wanted to say
that phases out over about a five-year
period
and the goal representative porter as i
mentioned is by the end of
these two phases
phase in of the
foundation opportunity budget to 100
phase out of the hardship grant the goal
is to get the number of school districts
that are receiving lower grants
down to a manageable level
doe is doing the real good data work
right now we'll be able to i think
determine from their work what that is
so uh i guess the question i would have
on the whole thing in this transition
where are you coming up with the funds
to support this transition i see in the
bottom here arp and some of the other
stuff but i'd like to have us a little
have a little bit of discussion on that
i'll start it but then let the other um
we have seen uh
other
there's let's take it your answer
provide the answer in two parts
representative
one part is the core of the foundation
opportunity plan
ends up spending
the same amount of state dollars
as this state currently has
in its education trust fund it's being
spent out of state property tax dollars
in fiscal year 2030 so the goal is to
fund the shift to foundation opportunity
budgets
with the same amount of dollars that are
in the current governmental plan are you
including the excess no uh
from the statewide education
absolutely yes
the second part of the
plan is how do you fund these hardship
grants
in other states
they have taken like massachusetts they
have taken the opportunity
to make equity changes in their public
school funding system
and they have funded transitions to that
using federal arpa dollars and other
federal grant dollars
this bill contemplates
using
available federal i was on gopher
and so i worked very closely on that
process i've continued to work with the
current gopher
uh in bfa
on other programs
so i know that these dollars exist
and the goal would be to
have this legislature
consider
this
part of this bill to be an important
priority
to protect communities from shocks in
their budget
and to take steps to allocate some of
those federal dollars to fund this uh
relief
has there been any discussion with
folks that are have the arpa and the
cares act funds has there been any kind
of discussion with these people to
determine whether there's a an
acceptance that
i don't want to see a whole harmless
become
stabilization
very very fair i'm going to answer and
then i'm going to be quiet for the
representatives who are currently
elected but i'll say
there has not been um that kind of
discussion largely because i feel
my own personal feeling is it's
presumptuous this committee starts first
in this process and you've started a
process of study
but your concern is of how to fund stuff
is
a very valid concern
thank you right but i think and i think
that's a very good question rick on on
this nobody wants to see
uh these transition grants turn into
stabilization and one of the very
important things about
about the design of
of the foundation opportunity plan is
that it does not rely on on 157 million
dollars of stabilization to shore up
a formula that doesn't work for many
many many school districts across the
state
what we'll see
next week and be able to explore is
really how this does work for for school
districts financially uh across the
state and how it works without the need
of um of 157 million dollars of
stabilization that's plugged in and
static and hasn't moved
you know since it was uh since it was
put in in
something like that well there was a
small hold harmless even back in 2008
but that was much more than 24 or 25
million
yeah so so um so
really important to look at the fact
that that that this transition grant is
a it's a it's a five-year
five-year transition it is it is fixed
in terms of what its costs
um are
and uh and so it it can be identified
prior to the plan going in place in
terms of where the source of funds um
uh would be uh could certainly come out
of other resources too but uh but the
way the bill the what what we're
envisioning is uh is that this would be
a very appropriate use of um of of
federal uh arpa dollars in order to help
uh help us transition into a program
like this all right do you
are we gonna in future
meetings we have here we have just a
couple more of them
are you gonna have a spreadsheet where
we could actually see for example are we
talking 157 million dollars
uh are we talking to
make the transition work or
what how much are you looking for it's
it's it's it's more like 250 million
dollars in that in that ballpark but
that's total
that's total over over the five years
okay so it's spread out over five so it
would be more in the first year less
than the second year
tapering down
so and at the bottom line is 200
approximately 250 million dollars
okay
let's keep marching yeah yeah so um so i
think we're on to to section we've we've
now covered
the
i'm just sort of reviewing the bidding
here we've covered the definition of
adequacy we've covered costing and we've
covered funding um now we're taking
taking a look at some of the i don't
want to call them edge cases because
they're all over the state but uh but
cooperative school districts and there's
nobody better than representative ames
since he represents towns that are in
cooperative school districts to talk us
talk through
three i've got three cooperative school
districts so just a small number
uh
this is uh this is just a little
detour that we don't need to spend any
time on
it's to ensure that the uh
funding that
is is calculated for a municipality
following the formula that ms dartinger
just laid out
where there's a minimum local
contribution and
a grant all based on characteristics of
the school district
is not that that those
conclusions those amounts are not then
reapportioned
based on a cooperative school formula so
what will be a portion continue to be a
portion is any spending in that school
district above
the adequacy level
that will be subject to the usual
cooperative school apportionment
formulas but
for the um
adequacy grants we wanted to be sure
that they stay intact and and what they
should be for each each municipality i
believe this language does that we can
get into the weeds i suppose and try to
make sure that that's the case but uh we
just wanted no reapportionment
of the
of the grants going to uh
that have been determined under this
bill
represent porter
so
again that means that hillsborough
deering is going to be one figure for
the deering kids and one figure for the
hillsborough kids
and they so
and that's what the budget will be
the grant will be
it won't be
all those kids smooshed together and one
figure for them okay just wanted to make
sure it will be one grant for a deer and
one grant for hillsboro okay thank you
so um
i'm sorry um linda's gotta
um yeah go ahead just uh
to expand it a little bit further
i represent part of the kearsarge
district
eight schools
eight towns um
so uh
each town would then have its own uh
could you explain that to me how that
works i see it with hillsboro during the
and the budget in most cases will
continue to be above what we're talking
about here
um and
and then
uh and it then it subtracts out federal
money that it may receive
and special grants that it may receive
like the uh
we talked about special education the
what uh that the special grant straight
from the state
um
that goes to the school district
now it's at a point
that money
um will then be
um apportioned according to the school
formula you've got eight
municipalities i'm sure there's lots of
there's quite a range of percentages
and now you've got
an apportion value that goes to
to each of those
municipalities
deducted from that
will be the
adequacy grant
that's
uh
that is has been figured under this bill
for that municipality
and then the municipality
uh
will um contribute the five dollars plus
whatever
extra is needed to meet that apportioned
um
at a portioned amount
it's been a long time since i've really
delved into the cooperative school
district
budget but it seemed to me it was
the apportionment was based on
adm
and part of it on that and part of it on
the tax base of the town
and i'm not sure how that splits up when
when you're counting adm
in the foundation grant as well um
we're trying not to mix the two okay
yeah
okay we can go through that in detail
we'll see if this this is part of the
bill that the uh
the ols will be uh giving us numbers on
not only oh that's the other one
lba sorry
uh we'll be giving us numbers on so
we'll see whether we've done it right or
or not uh the goal is to not
not have what's done here
refigured through a cooperative abortion
or
process
those agreements in these cooperative
districts between the districts
and how they proportion or apportion the
dollars
uh
well just like uh
no we're going to try to maintain the
integrity of this system
and respect the apportionment formulas
as they apply to
funds that need to be properly
apportioned
for each
district well
representative
thank you very much uh mr chair so
let me just
strip this down if you will
representative so these amounts the that
communities will be receiving
under this plan they're going to those
amounts are going to be determined by
real life kids with real live needs not
just
whether or not the kid exists but
whether or not they have english learner
needs special education needs poverty
needs right
so
in the cooperative districts or in all
districts for that matter
the the money that's coming in is going
to be determined by how much of that
needs to be offset
the the ell needs the special ed needs
right because
communities with higher numbers will
have higher needs
am i correct in in boiling it down to
that and the grant money will reflect
those needs right yeah
okay thank you
based upon the sending or the
participant district or the
i guess i i i
so yeah yeah so i got that i guess i
need to see a speech so just like what
the doe does right now where they where
they provide the adequacy grant on a on
a municipal
level even if you're a member of a of a
co-op
the number of students let's say in
hillsboro and the number of students
endearing and each will get a
get a get a grant calculation from from
the department
hillsborough will have a foundation
opportunity budget as calculated in
sections three and four on this deering
will get a foundation opportunity budget
hill hillsborough deering co-op might
have i'm making it up
you know maybe
um two-thirds of their budget comes from
hillsboro one-third of their budget
comes from deering i mean i don't know
whatever it happens to be but prior to
they get to that part
deering would contribute its foundation
opportunity budget in to the mix
hillsboro would put its foundation
opportunity budget into the mix remember
the foundation opportunity budget is
made up by the local minimum
contribution plus any additional money
that comes from the state to get you
there and then whatever is left
what is short you know what whatever
hillsborough deering co-op approves as a
budget if it's
greater than that then then then those
dollars would be subject to the co-op
agreement
but but the foundation opportunity
budget is calculated the same way
that i mean very similar you know
according to a formula
how um how the cost of inadequate
education is calculated today
yeah i was
going to i was driving towards this cat
aid type situation
the cat aids paid by the co-op but the
cost of that
specific shouldn't child or
program service shouldn't go back to
that sending district should it or or
how is that going to be handled
the uh
yeah that's right special ed aid right
right i believe that's done on a
lagging by one year okay right it's
totally a separate picture and that
categorical grant is is is taken out of
the
the doe 25 costs that are being used
so i just don't want to get into this
mixing them together here so so um so if
if you would like um mr chair i think we
can get through the next um few sections
i'm sorry
yeah so
we've come up with this formula for each
community based on the needs in the
community and we're making sure that
when we go
to the cooperative school district that
each community is still separately
getting
their needs met you know the money for
their needs
and then potentially plus whatever else
which will be divided according to the
thing but my question is we've given
this money
to you know
looked at each individual community and
figured out what the needs of that
community are but then once all that
money goes to the cooperative district
how are we making sure that it gets
spent
so i think that's thank you for the the
question representative leakes i think
the important thing to to recognize
uh in section four
sections three and section four in
building those that foundation
opportunity budget for every every
municipality whether they're whether
they run operate their own school
district or whether they're uh members
of a cooperative or regional
school district is that is that that
foundation opportunity budget or those
foundation opportunity budgets for in
the case of a cooperative or regional um
is for the school district to educate
all of the students
to to that outcome and that's how these
have been been calculated
that's how the foundation opportunity
budget is calculated so so like we you
know talked about earlier different um
school different school districts
may spend different amounts on on
whether it's special education or
english language learning or
or programs for um
you know for
for students across their you know in
their in their school district whether
it's extracurricular act or
co-curricular activities
um advanced placement classes stuff like
that um uh they they they have they have
discretion to uh to to spend it the way
the school board would like and that's
part of that that partnership between
local between state and local um local
governments and we're going to be
getting into the accountability section
very very soon
um hopefully we had one more question i
know this
right now all this is we don't target
money
uh
you receive the pot of money you
district use the money
but that's always an age-old question
accountability but uh representative
representative cordelli could i just
supplement dave's answer to the and then
i'll shut up
they're you're asking how do we know
that this is being used in a way to
achieve these goals
one thing we don't do is disrupt local
government
agreements so the cooperative agreements
right now are operating this bill
doesn't alter those at all
but the other thing we know is there's a
10-year
at least you know even shorter check
on whether the opportunity gaps are
being closed or not that's in the
accountability section that you'll see
and that is
more
aggressive uh and coordinated
checking on whether we're achieving
performance goals than any education
funding proposal that i've seen yet in
the last three decades and one of the
things the supreme court
mandated in its claremont cases was
a system that doesn't have
accountability
is not a constitutional system
this proposal has greater accountability
than anyone i've seen today
represent cornelli
uh thank you
um just wondering we talked about a
little bit about co-ops how about
districts that tuition their students
to either another district
or to a private school
how do they how would they fit into this
uh system
so thanks for the the question
representative cordelli so
the same way
the same way schools that um the same
way
municipalities that do operate their own
their own public schools they'll receive
they they'll receive a foundation
opportunity budget as calculated by
their um
by or as uh yeah is calculated by the
the um the students that they um they
serve and the characteristics of the
district that they're in
and um and then
that
any any additional resources that uh
that they need over and above that
foundation opportunity uh budget they
would uh raise through local property
taxes if it's if the foundation
opportunity budget was insufficient
to
levels that that are required by that
district and or required in the tuition
agreement and um and then they'd uh
they'd proceed um they'd proceed forth
uh with that but uh
very much the same as the the way that
it happens right now between between the
um the minimum local contribution the
grant that comes from the state
comprising that foundation budget and
then any additional
costs that that that that that
municipality would incur through through
tuition
agreements they'd have to make up the
difference and uh
just as they do today
you're a follow-up yes thank you um
just wondering how that would work
though with
some of the criteria in the formula such
as the size of the school district would
that be the size of the school district
of the sending
district or they might be sending it to
a district that's considerably larger
would you be factoring in the size of
the school that those kids are actually
going to
that that that's exactly a
representative cordelli you'd factor in
the size the characteristics of the
district that they're attending or the
school that they're attending
okay that's
you're absolutely right okay so then
then that section should read the
size of the school district
um that they are
of attendance
rather than
resident so you're talking adm a and
admr and that would have to be defined
in here correct
i think that's a good that's
that i think that's a very good good
suggestion
yes
yeah i i they do that basically
now with their tuition agreements i know
there's one
school district below me that sends to
five different high schools
and of all different sizes and costs
those adjustments are going to have to
be made by that sending
district
okay let's go on here all right we'll
keep going we're at the top of page nine
and uh i think we can get through this
um um
very quickly and and dick do you want to
speak to these or i'm happy to to move
through
so so so a lot of this we've already
talked about
the section 8 actually defines what that
minimum foundation budget contribution
is for every municipality uh in the
state and and as was said earlier
it's um it's the lower of five uh
dollars per thousand uh as a local
education property tax or
such a lower rate and i'm on line nine
uh on the top of page eight or such
lower rate
that um that is sufficient to to raise
the amount of local funds
uh necessary to um to to reach the um
the foundation opportunity budget so
there will be some municipalities across
the state
that
that will be paying less than five
dollars per thousand in order to uh to
get to that number section nine
um
of uh let's see section nine here oh
basically it's it's sort of it's i would
call it housekeeping but it basically
adds the transition grants as being a um
an expense that can be carried through
the education trust fund so the
education trust fund would see you know
transfers of at least based on this
arpa fund sufficient to
to um to meet the needs of the uh
or the demands of the transition grants
going through the education trust fund
uh and now we really get into section 10
uh which really begins accountability
and i think this goes to what
representative porter had um had asked
earlier and um
and this is this is amended um
an amendment to existing language so so
uh not all of it only the um only the
bold um uh
fonts are where changes uh uh
are made but you can see as the as as
you turn over to page nine
and uh and into page ten
uh it actually ends on um on halfway
down uh page ten
but uh but and i'm not going to get into
all of these different uh pieces of data
and this doesn't have to be an
exhaustive list either uh but these are
these are things that
uh that the department would would be
collecting
uh from uh from every um
municipal or every school district on
the doe 25 and some of these things
would be able to be used
for measuring um
results student performance student
outcomes and some of them may be
helpful as far as being able to consider
other differentiated aid factors
you know do we have the right factors
between free and reduced price launch
english english language learning and
special education
maybe that's what we use right now but
there may be others as well and so uh so
these are
these would be data that uh that could
be uh collected by the department uh and
uh and used both in in in outcome
determinations as well as some future
funding formulas as um as bill larger
mentioned
the formula would be updated certainly
no less frequently than every 10 years
and uh and so this would give the the
state the opportunity or the department
the opportunity to uh to consider
information
um going into section 11 we really get
into the the accountability
of you know pieces and you can see on
line
34 on page 10 where where we talk about
the specific data that
that ties into student outcomes
performance on statewide assessment
tests graduation rates attendance rates
and um and looking at what would be the
the lowest performing 20
of of schools
and um and you know and i think there's
there's got to be a lot of work on this
i mean this is this is not an area to be
taken lightly and it's not something
that we that we want to be considered to
be punitive or pejorative or you're a
bad school district or anything like
that um
we want this to be constructive
and and really put the state in a
position through the department
where where we can lend a hand to uh to
provide districts that
that geez you know we're spending we're
we're we're using the money where we
thought it would be best but it just
doesn't happen to be working that way
well what can the uh what can the state
suggest to do how can you help and
that's where um
where where you know things begin really
taking up
uh on page 11 on line 8 starting in
section 12
with a local education improvement plan
and um and and it's created by the
superintendent of uh of these districts
but also with the support from the uh
from the commissioner
and uh to put together a turnaround plan
for these these lowest performing 20 of
schools so you're constantly you're not
saying that these are bad schools but
you're constantly um looking for for
improvement and um and this is the the
the bottom 20 is something that has been
um been actually is used in a lot of
businesses uh as well
during um uh during during employee
i'm sorry employee reviews
um so uh so it so it does provide um
provide feedback
support from from the department
um
uh again you've got um you know sort of
at the middle of of page 11 lines 24
through
where where you're looking at how
budgets are being spent
and whether or not that spending is
really
efficient to drive outcomes
and
and you know one of the things that's um
that
tends to be true and i think um um mr
artinger asked me to comment on it
earlier about uh
spending efficiency um
there's a there's it wiggles around a
little bit and it and it usually ties to
it's it's it's it's pretty tight to the
um the the resources that are available
in a in a community so in a community
that has access to
to um to a lot of resources through high
property wealth per uh per pupil you may
actually see some less efficient
spending than in a district
um let's say you know newport which has
one of the highest um
local education tax rates in the state
uh they're looking to spend that money
as efficiently as possible so um so
being having the state come in and being
able to help um
administrations uh help school
administrators identify um uh spending
efficiency is uh is part of those
turnaround plans
uh let's see we're going on to 12 and
we're going to get page 12 and we're
going to get into
[Music]
wrap up the accountability section
um
you know i think at the top of page 12
we're really talking about sort of um a
deeper analysis on
on on student outcomes uh what sort of
things can what additional factors could
be considered in terms of student
outcomes safety and disa safety and
discipline
again achievement on on tests
college readiness so looking at like
line 10
and
some of the things that i think
represented porter was talking about
and then
and then beginning on line 14
we go into section 13
where um where and this is a very uh you
know interesting this is a new a new
area
um
where uh where we talk about um
persistent disparities and uh where
where certain subgroups and again these
subgroups could be identified through
data collection that's currently
happening or through the the new data
collection that's part of this this
accountability section
and uh how are subgroups uh performing
in terms of outcomes and um and how can
the state
through a
a um requesting a three-year plan from
local administrators um help uh help to
improve and that's where
for
results for for students in these
subgroups and that's really what you see
on the bottom of page 12 beginning in
romans 3 and there's a few things
suggested
uh here um
the the budget evidence-based program
sorry about that trying to move us
quickly through through this
um
on now on page 13 line 13
identification of outcome metrics um
uh that are being used by the by the
district and um
and uh uh and then line 20 uh how will
the district um helped to improve parent
engagement in uh in their students
learning so uh so these are things that
are that are really long term
um it's it's
particularly in the in the persistent um
uh category of persistent disparities
and they may not be able to be you you
may not be able to measure differences
in in any given month or in any given
year but uh but hopefully uh seeing
those those disparities um
taper down or or close those gaps um as
um you know over the long term based on
based on the um
the the uh
the plants uh jointly put together by
the the local administrators and the uh
the department so that brings us to the
page of uh the top of page 14
and uh and we really swing um now into
into revenue policy and i
would uh would love to turn it back over
to uh to um to mr artinger and
representative ames to drive us through
this
yeah uh so we're looking at uh section
on page 14 and then
um
skipping a few
uh
taking up again at section 18 on page 16
through 23 and these all have to do with
the statewide education property tax
and
we start with the section 14 where we're
simply
reaffirming that we're staying at the
same level that we
will
have been at we we will
be at the 363 million dollar level
according to this there's just no
attempt to change
uh the level and that's what the
education tax will revert to after
fiscal year 23 which as you know is down
that's all that section 14 does and then
in sections the other sections
i did
provide you with a one-pager for these
tax sections the reason that was easy
for me to do
is that uh
these sections are also exactly the same
as the sections that are in
house bill 504
which is a bill that weighs a means
handled
and which has been
um sent to interim study by vote of the
house in january
so
we've simply
put those sections into this bill
because we think they're an integral
part
and very important to this bill with
respect to the property tax
aspects of the bill
there is a key provision
in 504 and in this bill
that mr hartinger will speak to and that
is
relates to what we all call
thank you in this bill
uh
under current law
there is a requirement that every
community
pay statewide property tax at a rate
that's established sufficient to get to
the 363
million dollar target
it's 263 for one of the years and now
and then it goes back to 363.
they
the issue is
for some communities
that rate
is not fully enforced in 2011
there was an amendment to our state
revenue statutes that said
whereas before
all communities had to calculate their
state property tax and to the extent
they
were able to use it to meet their
adequate education grant
target
they would keep it all
but some communities raised so much
money that it was far above their
adequate education number and what the
prior to 2011 they had to take that
excess and pay it to the state treasurer
so their taxpayers were paying at the
same rate
that every other taxpayer in the state
was in 2011 that was changed
so no longer did a community which had
excess state property tax were they
required to pay it to the state
and what we heard in the commission is
are really using that money
to reduce
the tax rates in those communities
meaning that some taxpayers
in in property wealthy communities are
paying a lower rate
for a state tax than other taxpayers
i in connection with house bill 504
i wrote a letter
to representative norm major the chair
of the house ways and means committee
this letter is provided to you on your
work in your group work group
and what it says
is that
we may not be facing a current lawsuit
here yet
but this is a big risk and we're talking
about literally
hundreds of millions of dollars every
year that are potentially being
collected through an unconstitutional
tax
that should be something that the state
of new hampshire cares about when it's
preparing its offering statements
and and dealing with potential
litigation risks
what this bill does
is following up with the commission
is say we're not going to take that risk
anymore we're going to correct it and so
every taxpayer
in the state
would be required to pay the state
property tax rate collected by their
local community
but the local community administration
would then turn those amounts
over to the state treasurer
minus cost of administration
and what that is designed to do
is number one
eliminate
this constitutional
threat
to the finances of the state of new
hampshire and that's in this bill it's
very very important to
in my view
just to finish this part of it uh
the uh
the other changes that are in the bill
that relate to uh
to the statewide education property tax
uh
go at uh amend the low and moderate
income
uh relief program property tax relief
program that's uh
that is an
integral part of the swept system
to
say it
and in shorthand
it uh it provides
more relief
and
higher eligible
and more people will be eligible
and
it also extends that relief to the
local property tax as well as the
statewide property tax so
it adds those two together
and then the relief is calculated
against
whatever the bill is that's come to the
particular
property tax payer
and
that means a larger sum a larger amount
of relief can be granted
the bill includes a cap on the total
amount that
of relief that will be available i
believe it's 25 million dollars
and that would be come out of the excess
swept of the money that
has come into the state treasury as a
result of this tax
uh so i think that's the gist of the uh
of the
statewide education property tax
provisions and if i i might add one
thing to this so
there's been an issue over the last
decades in school funding about donor
towns
donor towns
this is what we've been talking about is
the solution to the donor town problem
i remember asking someone from a donor
town in the administration of their
donor of their their government do you
the town
pay
property tax do you pay property tax
the answer of course is no no town or
city pays property tax who pays it
taxpayers pay individual taxpayers
the solution that representative ames
has identified has an elegance to it in
my view which is
we're not going to provide tax relief
to an entire city and town which is then
distributed
to taxpayers who may need the
benefit and taxpayers who don't
what we're going to do instead is
refocus that
to provide targeted relief for taxpayers
who have the greatest need those are low
and moderate income
property tax owners and so
when the donor towns come and say hey
under this plan which may have a
constitutionally positive thing about it
we're going to be a donor town again
remember they don't pay taxes their
taxpayers do and this bill
provides
the most robust
property tax relief
that i've seen
in
and i've been a tax lawyer in new
hampshire i served on the ways and means
committee when i was 19 years old that
that in in that whole time this is real
property tax relief but it's not given
to towns
or cities
and all indiscriminately taller tax
rates it's given into targeted
individual taxpayers with low and
griffs and boom
thank you
yeah i've always said in my town i mean
it's not a statewide property tax it's
the local property taxes it never leaves
the town
and i agree with you i think this maybe
hey maybe should be a separate bill i
mean
it's been there
i mean it's it should be i mean yeah 504
is it yeah because it it's not a
statewide property tax if it doesn't
leave your town i mean come on
i mean that's why i said let's do away
with it because it doesn't help in my
town it just it's your property tax the
two together
so
hey let's use it as a statewide property
tax because we know there are some towns
that don't have schools and
and they're keeping the money i mean it
should go to the state
has a statewide property taxes just one
might comment thank you rep santana
yes this is an area probably i get
hammered from uh because of sunapee in
my district
and um
the one of the arguments with sunapee is
uh and obviously other towns that are in
the same category of centipede
is that yes we have a grand list that's
you know very large but at the same time
within that town
we have a certain number of property
owners
who
have low incomes or fixed incomes
and do not it's not reflected in you
know our taxes because the property is
valued assessed so high
uh in our area and it's gone out of
sight in the last
two years with uh covid
our assessments have you know
really gone crazy
so how do i go back
to that town
and explain to them
uh
what this all means
and why they shouldn't consider
themselves a donor town
and then i would say that um there are
two
points that need to be made one is the
law
that
from a constitutional point of view this
is
a statewide tax it's collected with the
help of the local
assessors and so forth
but
it is a statewide tax and all state wide
taxes get paid into the state treasury
and then paid out and that's how this
should be
and the second thing is
that
is the property tax relief part of this
and this enables for the people in your
district in santa fe
that
are hurting because of the tax levels
um even though
on the whole sanofi looks like a wealthy
district i'm sure there are people in
there
who
are
either because of temporary
circumstances or for the long haul
unable to
keep up with
the rise in the property tax bill this
provides a vehicle for relief i should
have said that there's
a provision in here that caps the
individual
relief that will be provided at a
thousand dollars
now that too could be changed but uh
we're trying to
trying to assert some control over cost
in uh putting this thing together but a
thousand dollars can be a big piece
of a bill
so we're not talking about peanuts here
we're talking about real relief
one one way representative it's
interesting you might have
different constituents come to you
one might
be someone who owns
and i grew up in corner she used to go
to sunapee all the time as a little high
school kid
it might come to you i got a second home
on job's creek
and it's worth millions of dollars
and how come
i'm paying this full tax at the rate
there's another person who might come to
you who says i've owned this property
with my family this cabin on jobs creek
and i haven't sold it yet to have it
rebuilt
and the taxes are killing me and i'm on
a fixed income
the answer that this bill gives is
we have a state tax and everyone's going
to pay tax at the same rate
everybody but we've also provided
special
targeted
tax relief
for you because you need it more
and and i think that's the answer that
is as direct as possible whereas the
prior donor town concept is
really
shielding that it's tax relief for
wealthy property taxpayers and
needy tax payers alike and i think
that's why this is a step forward for
foreign
well representative vlad i
well i guess we can probably tag team
this a little bit and folks are okay
i'll just try to pronounce it a little
more
again chuck lloyd president up at white
mountains community college i've been in
the community college system for about
19 years or so now
first at nhti in concord now up north
up north we serve
littleton
berlin north conway and we're online the
question representative ladd is about uh
two plus twos three plus ones any
articulation and the short answer is yes
we do a little of all of that
we do significant amount of two plus two
where students will come for two years
get their associate degree in that
entire package if you will will be taken
on to the university system whether it's
plymouth keene granite state college has
been a great partner in the past and
also you know in our northern new
hampshire plymouth state university
one program i like to
speak to is our north country teacher
certification program what that is is
our students will come through our white
mountains community college teacher
education program for two years they
will stay on and complete their
bachelor's degree in berlin at the
berlin campus through plymouth state
university that's our great relationship
with plymouth and they end up getting a
bachelor's degree physically on the
berlin campus it just happens to be
plymouth state's degree
so it saves our students the commuting
back and forth to plymouth which you
know i know plymouth i can say this
because i'm a i'm a graduate of plymouth
state plymouth says they're in the north
country there's a lot more further north
beyond plymouth so our our students who
are in berlin it would be an hour and 15
minutes you know back and forth so
that's one of the models we're also
looking at uh three plus one types of
models and other programs uh whereas
students can complete their associate
degree and then maybe go into a
different program for example liberal
arts get another you know 24 to 30
credits
i'll only add to that that the one
unique program that that you re
reference representative ladd is the rn
to bsn program which is specifically set
up as a three plus one program where the
students are taking 90 credits through
the community college system
the last 30 credits taken through
granite state college on behalf of the
university system are still done at the
community college system tuition rate so
adding to the savings for students
well it's a grant it's currently a
degrees
with articulation agreements with all of
the community college each of the
community colleges they have to be
institution to institutions
and then in a number of them
um
at nhti
great bay there are additional
you
oh
yes and yes i guess number one i guess
this is working now
number one if a student knows as they're
coming into white mountain community
college where they want to eventually
transfer that's that's ideal you know
whether it's plymouth state working with
a block transfer which has been very
successful or if a student you know
knows they want to eventually go to unh
but start their first two years if you
know in advance we can work backwards
and that's probably the easiest to do
the second part of this when you mention
you know if a student figures out along
the way say they get a year year and a
half in
the exact moment they know where they
want to go what they want to do we
connect them with an advisor you know
matt and i communicate all the time to
say all right you want to go to plymouth
let's start mapping out what do you have
done so far how will that apply but also
what do you take next how much can you
take you know the relationship with
plymouth has been great because it's not
necessarily plymouth to say all right
let's get you as fast as we can
let's get you when it makes sense for
you
in that okay if you stay another
semester you can save some money you
don't need to come down yet because you
can get your general education out of
the way now you're getting into the core
discipline you know walking in as a
junior now's the time where you'll want
to come down and figuring out what that
looks like
so there is a it's a constant back and
forth to say it's you know perfect and
lined up at every single way no it's
yes uh reversing woodcock
thank you
gentlemen thank you for being here um
sort of the same idea i was just
wondering is there a reason and i'm
probably wrong there's a reason why
students can't take two years at any of
the community colleges and automatically
move in as a full junior
at all at all of the
four-year at keane and
plymouth and
all of them i mean is there's a reason
why or am i wrong they can
i'd like to just reinforce what reps on
woodcock's saying right now you all have
in front of you
we have a statute from tennessee
if you did you get that
and i'll read it because it's i think
it's echoing exactly what represented
woodcock is saying it says an associate
of science or associate of arts degree
graduate from a tennessee community
college
shall be deemed to have met all general
education and university parallel core
requirements
for for transfer to a tennessee public
university as a junior
notwithstanding this subdivision that
i'm reading right here admission into a
particular program school or college
within a university or in to the
university of tennessee knoxville shall
remain competitive competitive in
accordance with generally applicable
policies so
i think that's along the line what
you're saying is that if you get an
associate's degree whether it be at
white mountain or on the southern part
of the state
why should that not
count as your first two years and you
come in if you're meeting the the
requirements as stipulated right here
and it's a competitive process as a
junior
or should it
so
a student who actually finishes the
associate degree has at least 60 credits
and as long as those credits are all
transferable in areas of the curriculum
offered by the four-year institutions
typically that student's going to have
junior standing but if the students
coming in
without the associate degree hasn't
fulfilled all the degree requirements in
the community college system and
depending on what program they were
pursuing if they're interested in
engineering they might or might not have
the prerequisites in math they might
have the 60 credits they may have
satisfied an associated requirement
still may not have the specific
prerequisites lined up with a particular
program no different than a student who
starts at unh in liberal arts and in the
junior year decides that she or he wants
to be an engineer may have to work
backwards and fulfill whether it's it's
chemistry or physics or calculus so
again the 60 credits and the associate
degree in hand generally will bring you
in at the junior level but whether
you've satisfied all the requirements
prerequisites that that now line you up
perfectly for your junior year in a
particular major is going to be
a product of which of the literally
hundred different majors are available
in the university system
is
yeah i'll take some of this and i'll
turn to my director of admissions at
plymouth state after uh you know i would
say yes i think the short answer is yes
as long as the students are educated
about the process and you know across
all of our 100 high schools i'm sure
there's a different level of school
counseling that happens also different
level
of outreach that occurs but by and large
i would say students know there are
pathways
you know the easiest one to say is
liberal arts which is general education
when you're coming in you know students
know that if they start basically at any
of the community colleges they can go to
any i'm going to say the word any if
it's in liberal arts and walk in as a
junior i think that's the easiest the
word i would also use is applicability
uh chancellor said it very eloquently
that you know depending on the program
if you start getting really specialized
you need to you know sometimes catch up
in different areas but the number of
credits does not change you're bringing
them in
so i think students coming out of high
school are well aware uh that there are
these articulation agreements you know
they were printed off of our websites i
think there were about four or five
pages of them
so i'd like to follow up you use the
word applicability
if you look at the tennessee statue it
says comparative in accordance with
generally applicable policies
so would that
would this statute that's there
um
cover what you you've just presented to
us saying applicability there's it looks
like they have that exception right here
has to be in accordance with the
i also defer to director admissions over
here a little bit yeah when i when we're
looking at students who are going to be
transferring in
we'll take the liberal arts block
transfer for instance
that program has 13 or so that we can
guarantee students coming in to
have completing in two years once
they're here
but if they're coming into nursing right
at most of the usnh schools it's very
hard to transfer in nursing because of
the course progression they want to come
in as a biology student there's certain
progressions of classes that in the
liberal arts associates degree they will
not have met those first and second year
requirements to then progress at that
same rate so
yes that's to say
if it works with the program with each
institution's curriculum they should be
able to make through but there's those
and
go ahead let uh moffitt and then you uh
kathy provincial
it's on deck
yeah thank you mr and as a true
north country native i want to say that
dr lloyd is correct that plymouth really
is not part of the north country
uh
representative ford is back he's the
sole sponsor of this measure and um
as i read it uh
it it reads uh about granting bachelor's
degrees and a program of study in which
a bachelor's degree is not offered or
available at any institution in the
university system he's back he can speak
to that as i read that i'm i'm thinking
i'm wondering if his sense is that maybe
this would you're trying to create
enabling legislation so that a community
college perhaps in a certain niche
could could develop a uh bachelor
program i guess not know that
representative ford's back maybe could
could
speak to that
thank you representative
uh
yes in the simple answer
what i was looking for was enabling a
discussion
which would address and i have
correspondence that i've had both with
chancellor and the predecessor in which
we had discussions both of us about the
goal was
to basically
make the transition from associate to
baccalaureate
an accessible reality
a reality device and i was thinking in
my mind of and i intentionally took
examples like the diesel engineering
technology and management
because i know that nobody ever
transferred from that to humanities
because i taught humanities for a long
time and it's just not something in the
mindset of people who are studying for
that that goes into this and so i took
two things that were polar opposite
and i just said if they wanted to
could they then proceed to a bachelor's
degree
and how would they do that and the thing
is there's no place to go no one else
offers that
so how could you if you say had it in
mind that you wanted to be a military
officer
to get a commission in the u.s military
you have to have a bachelor's degree
it doesn't matter what it's in it could
be in french history
but you have to have a bachelor's degree
then you can get a commission
and then if you're like me suddenly one
day they look at you and say you're the
motor transport officer i have a degree
in english
you see the disconnect
but the guy in that diesel technology he
knows all about that he could have done
a much better job or she for that matter
than i could have done
no matter how long i stayed doing it
and so i'm thinking in those
terminologies when we're educating
students typically we talk about
students
working in a job that's here but not all
the careers our students aspire to are
here
some of them are with the federal
government or the army or anybody else
and so i'm looking at how do we get that
person
into
that career path
and the probability just like the the
para educators
who are bound to a place and want to
become a teacher they can't go away to
college they have families they have
jobs they need health care
part of the problem we have to sign
to have to solve is how to get them what
they need in order to make that possible
and that's
to answer your question representative
that's the motive behind all of this
is how do we provide
access to baccalaureate education via
the community colleges
by via mean they might be the first two
years and then where does that go well
if that receiving institution
has faculty that don't want to travel
down there does that block the will of
the state
how do we accomplish that
that's what i see that's being discussed
is how do we make that possible
uh reps uh uh kathy provencher had her
hand up and we went with moffitt uh
maybe you know and then you take over i
think we should have the
no longer chancellor
no longer state treasurer
kathy provencher you
you
do you have your button pushed there
there
if a student at the community college
system
knows what path they want to take and um
chuck's right that's not always the case
but again there there are there are a
pathway to
30 plus degrees that you could transfer
from
any community college
to
one of the one of the universe biology
is one of them
um
again if if you didn't know that when
you entered
school you might have to pick up a
course here or there but there again
it's online very clear pathways to
the a degree that that
will transfer
and to representative ford's earlier
comment
you're right i don't i i don't with the
diesel mechanics i don't know anything
about that so i don't there's probably i
don't know if there's a
i'd be happy to take that question a
need or you know for that
a program like that
if the chair would like i can address
that question specifically no i'm i'm no
longer chair i'm not the chair of the
subcommittee chair of education
representative ford is the chair of the
subcommittee
thank you diesel heavy equipment
technology great program these are the
folks that are working on on-road
off-road equipment uh milton caterpillar
john d or kubota to kenworth trucks mack
trucks i mean these are these are the
people that keep things going uh
it's an excellent program when we're
thinking about bachelor's degree you
know articulation or transfer we say if
there is somebody that is interested do
we have a partner and i'm sorry i can't
see you with obstructed few here do we
have a partner that is interested in
offering that program and in this case
global skill up in new york has a
program we've sent two students in the
last 13 years to that
to complete the bachelor's degree just
for what you're saying if something does
require a bachelor's degree they've got
it a lot of those students wind up if
they want to pursue higher ed they'll
get a business or accounting degree
because they'll either open their own
business they'll work up into management
senior management at milton cad or
whatever it might be but we also look
about student interest just like kathy
provincial was just saying is there an
interest our students typically will
come in for a certificate an associate's
degree or they can go right out you know
after that and start making great money
frankly right away with that associate
degree or
or otherwise
the other piece we look at is industry
demand meaning is it an entry point will
people be hired with a certificate or an
associate degree or is the bachelor's
degree required at this point not even
just given this current you know economy
but even prior years back
the entry point is a certificate or
associate degree to get hired to get
promoted to work your way and have a
great job so it's not necessarily a
barrier to not have that bachelor's
degree so those are typically the three
areas we spend time on is is there an
industry need is there student interest
or is there an existing pathway
in this case you know we check all of
those boxes for diesel heavy equipment
which you know it is we are the only one
in new hampshire with the only
accredited new england i'm not sure the
university system wants to get into that
particular area you know for a transfer
but you know right now that checks all
the boxes and i know you're just using
that as an example but we use that same
philosophy whenever we're looking at any
of our programs working through each of
those three areas
thank you
one of the things that led me to that
question is my own personal experience
i started out as a geology major
i switched to english when there were no
jobs in geology
i was working in an oil company when
that happened
there were people down the street with
master's degrees from colorado school of
mines and they were selling used cars
that's not exactly an incentive to
finish your major and plunge ahead
so i shifted to english i had no idea
what that involved it was just
fortuitous that at my university all the
gen ed and everything fit but i wound up
taking a lot of science courses micro
paleontology for example that most
people didn't take
but when they i look at those
people who are in the jobs like para
educator who are not from this country
don't speak english as a native language
don't trust banks
the banks are working to get them to be
banked
and so they're trying to train people in
high school about how to work in a bank
and what you need to know and they're
buying the computers
so i look at myself and i'm looking at
our situation thinking
anybody else
what does that do when we say these
people get health insurance or these
people need a computer to do it when
we're not providing it for every other
kid in the state
but these students are different
many are married with families
and they're dependent on that health and
they cannot progress in their careers
toward becoming a teacher which would be
a benefit to us all because they're
already bilingual
so we get two banks for the buck
but we can't get them there without
mr
the kind of question i'm throwing out mr
chair i got a question here yeah and
there's several questions i think others
um
is it so that if you're
graduate with a two-year associate's
degree from white mountain
you can go down to psu now and enroll as
a junior
is that irregardless of what your
associate's degree is in
or is it a standard operating procedure
you walk in as a junior
in accordance with you know
in accordance with the you know the
admission
uh prerequisites at that particular
degree you might be seeking i would say
in most programs i'll go back to what
matt was saying earlier of you know in
in nursing it might be difficult
depending on the sequencing uh maybe a
couple of other programs but i would say
by and large i think you listed 13. we
have a great new block transfer you know
arrangement that has worked out really
well
i would never say a hundred percent all
or i would never use the word
representative uh
uh woodson would saw excuse me glare
over there
you use the word automatically and i
never use automatically uh but by and
represent woodcock
sure i'm just i was trying to get a
clarity from rather than forward on his
bill
i know he's leaving
um
bill
specifically the work session was around
the bill that i presume yes i understand
the pathway system um
this bill as is
you all have a chance to see it or read
it okay so if i understand what he's
looking for besides
the connection um that he's specifically
looking for community colleges like
white mountain
to be able to have the ability to offer
baccalaureates
under this bill
so i'm hoping that uh while you're here
you can address the intent of the bill
um
because that's that's that's where we go
that's where this is going
versus the dialogue on the pathway yeah
and it probably should be stated for
this group we've invited representative
ford to come to a subcommittee of our
board of trustees he came
student success committee we talked you
know quite at length actually
as the community college system of new
hampshire we're already authorized to
offer bachelor's degrees it's in our
statutes i believe it's a board of
trustee policy
so we are allowed to uh for us we've
really chosen to work with our existing
partners
and really evaluate articulation just
through that so
i don't know about enabling legislation
but we are currently allowed to i i
would ask
where did you find that statute if
if i might sir
the the language in statute in 188f
basically says that we are up
we are authorized to award degrees as is
common for
two-year institutions i'm familiar with
that part of it we don't presume that
that's the intent of the legislature and
similar to the university system in
asking the legislature for clarity about
whether granite state the merger with
unh is
acceptable we would we would certainly
come back but we do think that the way
the language is currently crafted now
that more than half of the states allow
community colleges to offer four-year
degrees we think that the language is is
there
i can just echo
what the
committee in higher education
study came up with what six years ago
and as a flat no
um you do not offer a four-year degree
at the community college level
that that's where they you know the
legislature was now we it's not in law
but i think that the message was
conveyed at that time
so i i if i may i as i said we we don't
presume that we understand that or or or
accept that that's
something we would do if we thought we
should do it we would come for
legislative
okay endorsement on that one
to the question that representative
woodcock asked earlier it's also not our
intent right now to offer four-year
degrees as president lloyd said our
interest is really in working with the
university system
the needs that our students have and and
align with what representative ford was
describing earlier the needs that
working adults have which are the
majority of our students are for the
education they need now it may be a
building block to a four-year degree
eventually but sometimes what they need
is what they need right now and our
effort is to try and provide things that
are more aligned with that need in the
workforce for working adults maybe a
certificate maybe an associate degree
maybe the course that they need that
takes them one step further than they
where where is your accreditation in
terms of
offering a four-year degree right now
you're accredited by the same
institution that credits the four years
so
when they
they say that your introductory course
and literature
is an is a
accredited course or you know you credit
the universe the system
but
tell me
is there anything any hoops you have to
jump through to to make it now a
four-year degree course or program or is
it just you got accredited so it's good
to go
we're regionally accredited by the new
england commission on higher education
the same accrediting body that that
accredits the usnh institutions but the
courses themselves are not accredited
we're we're authorized to award degrees
if we wanted to begin to offer
additional degrees at a different level
we would go back and file for
substantive change so netchie would
require you to come back
and
state that now we're going for a
four-year degree i believe that's
represent like us
i'm wondering
in actuality as opposed to just
principle
how transferable
are each of the courses that you take
for instance if i take two semesters of
an english
at
wherever
and then i go
to someplace else
how you know how specific does it have
to be
so
prevailing guidelines regionally
accredited institutions will typically
accept as transfer credit coursework
that's documented on an official
transcript with a grade of c or better
for a regionally another regionally
accredited institution so the credits
almost always will transfer as long as
that receiving institution offers the
program in the same area of the
curriculum
the place where it sometimes gets
complicated is whether it satisfies a
degree requirement so you may end up
with a lot of elective credits
transferring but not necessarily making
progress toward a degree
over the last several years a good deal
of work has been done our colleague
leslie barber who's a faculty member at
great bay community college has done
extensive work with the university
system to map individual courses course
by course so that the course actually
satisfies a specific requirement at the
usnh institutions beyond that uh what mr
wallace was describing for for plymouth
the block transfer
regardless of what the courses were and
i assume this is true regardless of what
the grade is the student who's
transferring the associate degree will
receive 60 credits and will start as a
junior in that program so it's
alleviated some of the
specifics of a grade below c for
instance and you know at a home
institution a student may receive credit
for passing a course with a d normally
that wouldn't transfer but under the
block arrangement i assume that that's
the exception
you are correct on that
that's just that's for business and
liberal arts not for all of our programs
okay and i was asking partly because my
daughter-in-law
took i can't tell you in you know the
gen ed courses i can't tell you how many
times because she kept you know it was
like well this year now our beginning
our freshman english now looks like this
and you took it last year and it doesn't
look like that
and i just wonder
that she was in massachusetts and i'm
wondering how here in new hampshire
how much
that's an issue or how much you say okay
you took it it was the freshman english
you know then and it counts as
i i think it's fair to say the work that
professor barber has done the work that
that plymouth has done the work that
granite has done all of that effort has
been to try and minimize the likelihood
that a student wastes time and money
having to repeat essentially the same
course students have almost always had
the opportunity to do credit by
examination to demonstrate the
proficiency but it's an additional step
and often it derails students or at
least becomes a barrier so we've done a
lot between the two systems to try and
lessen the likelihood that that happens
thank you very much in section two of
this bill
there's a roman 17 a which will
authorize would authorize if it became
law the community college to offer
four-year degrees if those four-year
degrees were not offered at the
university system level
um i'd be curious to know what is your
position on that i'd like to also know
from the university system what their
as president lloyd described earlier
we've we first want to make sure that
there's a value to the student that
there's a real demand for that in the
marketplace that employers would value
it that students want it and that it
justifies the cost of delivering it if
all of those conditions were met we
would approach the university system to
see if we could not get a partnership to
deliver similar what dr lloyd has
created with plymouth on the education
program
uh kathy can you respond to that i'd
like for example
i don't know i don't think
university of new hampshire has a
physical therapy maybe they do now or
maybe yeah they do have that they come
from the main to your physical therapy
program but there must be some programs
that you don't offer that you have
agreements with other states for our
students to go to
is that's one way of handling this
rather than the community college system
starting a new program up i'm just a
little confused as far as where we're
going here
in
expanding programs at a time when we are
trying to
you know realize that our
our margins shrinking and shrinking and
shrinking i think representative i mean
that's our concern as
the community college system is
it's not a good time to expand programs
we'd have to really understand what the
demand is
president lloyd mentioned there were two
people in the last 13 years that wanted
a bachelor's degree in diesel mechanics
and they found a place for them in new
york
that's probably of
that is a good way to handle it rather
than develop a four-year degree
when the demand isn't there
so um
and and you're spot on representative
lad
our
our pool of students is shrinking
and so we need to think about that for
the future and
uh to chancellor rubenstein's point if
there is a demand for a four-year degree
we should work together and
the other thing we haven't talked about
because it's not degree related but um
credent micro credentialing and badging
is is really
where much of higher education is going
that we add on or
help a student
stack on
credentials rather than degree seeking
and
community college system and university
system also in the middle of
those conversations to see how we
partner
to benefit
a whole host of students and
and businesses in
micro credentialing and badging i've got
to leave in a few moments that's a
discussion we need to get into i hope
the community college system has been
very aggressive in seeking these skill
pathways and and certification
credentials
and you mentioned shrinking demographic
if
the four-year system starts doing what
the two-year system has been chasing the
two-year system starts going in the
direction what the four year is
um
are we doing the what we should be doing
you talk about collaboration that seems
like a better way of
moving down the road to me
than than everybody's starting to take
everybody else's
bailiwick
well that's what that's what is so
important about continuing to partner
right we're just gonna eat each other
and that's not going to serve
either system or the state or students
so it's
it's our new reality
yeah i and maybe represent luna can talk
to some of the mission statements or the
purpose of where we're going
representative
um
not um
maybe
uh
um
in
as particular
um
uh
i'm on my way out the door right now to
see another president so
i've got to leave right now i'm going to
go back up and talk to don right now
but i
my my hope is that
that somewhere along the way that a
person that completes an associate's
degree
can walk into a four-year school as a
junior
if that person measures up to the
applicable
rationale and prerequisites for the
program they're walking into a and i
would hope that all the courses that you
take innocent associates level would
count towards a liberal arts student
coming in in any one of our
four or three
campuses right now uh at the university
level as a junior
the the economy today
the costs
of an education are horrendous and
we can't afford to
lose
uh investment that some of these
students have by taking courses and not
having them
lead to that four-year degree that
representative ford is talking about
in the military they're just looking for
that degree
you can become an officer
my degree was in history it qualified me
to enlist and then become an officer by
a different path
you can do that now
that's
again if you know what you know that's
the path you take and you take these
courses you'll come in as a junior so if
i
i want to go into the gen eds and want
to go to keene state
and i have the
the four-year degree can i enroll in
keene state as uh junior in liberal arts
i believe so
nursing liberal arts is probably the
easiest
again then if i want to transfer another
program then i'm gonna have to you know
take all those prerequisites i might
graduate as a fifth year student or a
six-year student right you look more
closely at that applicability which
program which courses you know but
liberal arts is probably the easiest one
i apologize i gotta run
well my my question here following on
rep luno and rep ford is
it seems to me that um in a lot of ways
the biggest difference between the
four-year schools and the community
college
is the delivery method so the community
college you're kind of you're local
you might be going days or nights
you might be you know not even full time
you're usually working a job that kind
of thing
whereas the university you might go away
too
you know i might go to university and
either get a dorm or an apartment or
whatever and live nearby
and
use all of those other facilities the
gym and all of that stuff that the
community college might not have
well if i'm in that situation where i'm
working and maybe raising kids or
whatever
and let's say i've
gotten my technical degree so i've done
the technical stuff at the community
college because that community college
offered that
could i
it's then what i'm missing is the gen ed
courses but then there are community
colleges that you get the gen ed courses
from so the question
to me is
it it would seem rather than having to
travel to get those gen ed courses at a
university
would it not be possible for me to get
those
there at the community college that's
down the road that i can
take my classes you know amongst my work
schedule etc and i think
that's my take on on what
rep ford was saying is how do you keep
the kid the kid
the adult usually who can't
go off to school
who has who has a location that they
need to be at
representative lake is
if i make
a student who wants a bachelor's degree
may start with us in a certificate
program maybe a purely
technical one-year certificate program
but that student has access to all of
the courses general education
prerequisites that would support
pursuing a bachelor's degree
so
part of what you heard president lloyd
described earlier in the partnership
with plymouth is figuring out
when you've made full use maximal use of
what the community college system can
offer the affordability the location the
convenience maximize all of that before
you need to to move for a bachelor's
degree depending on what the program is
could be as it could be a fully online
bachelor's degree and you don't have to
move
it could be that it is a location-based
program and you actually do have to do
that but again there are ways to
maximize what we can do through the
community college system supporting the
access mission that we have contributing
to the affordability of that degree
it really depends on the specific
program and a lot of it comes down to
good advising the articulation
agreements map out in general terms that
a student who follows this roadmap
here's how it will land
a lot of our students lives haven't lent
themselves to a specific roadmap because
they've taken pretty circuitous routes
at that point really comes down to the
personalized advising somebody who can
sit down between the two sets of
institutions and say this is where you
are
this is a map that can get you
specifically
to this location
it's not a cookie cutter it's it's going
to be really tailored
so
i can understand if you just took gen
egg has courses at the
community college it whether it's near
you might not offer the technical
courses that you wanted but if the
community college offers the technical
courses
and i think most community colleges
offer gen ed courses
is there a reason why the community
college couldn't then offer the
bachelor's
typically the distinction is going to be
the major required courses at the upper
level
more advanced courses
it doesn't necessarily mean that our
faculty are not qualified to do that but
our faculty are typically focused on the
courses that contribute to the associate
degree or the certificates that we have
so some of it is a resource question and
capacity and some of that is better
addressed with collaboration through the
university system i i will say that that
some of this is still
about location
and as you described earlier the
experience for a lot of our students who
are working adults as opposed to a
full-time student who immerses
themselves in a particular campus at a
location away from home our students
have lives with families and jobs and
other things so it's one course at a
time and the ability to conveniently do
that you know again as opposed to having
a uh
an efficient way to do that for that one
particular student at our location
you know that that's why those two
students with the diesel uh mechanic
technology program went to cobbleskill
because that was just a more efficient
way for us to do that we can't afford
the luxury of that that specific
customization i was thinking i was
thinking partly rn for i mean an rn
two-year program versus an rn four-year
program
and
i keep asking what's the difference and
i get told it's the gen ed courses
and since some community colleges are
offering
rns could they not then
allow the students as they have time to
take those gen egg courses
and give the four-year bachelor's i mean
that's
well i'll always say it's a little bit
more than the general education courses
our students after two years are
qualified to pursue the nclex the the
licensure exam for nurses they become
working nurses they are in the field and
contributing to the state's health care
workforce that bachelor's degree is two
additional years it includes additional
coursework in the program in the in
nursing as well as additional uh courses
in general education as well as
additional clinical experience so it's
not it's not quite as as easy as
additional general education courses
again it would require an expansion of
capacity but that was the reason why the
community college system the university
system partnered
nine years ago to create the rn to bsn
program increase access affordability
allowing students to maintain the
community college system tuition rate
all the way through four years and and
kept them with the community college
system for three of those four years to
facilitate an easier transition
thank you you're welcome mr sub
committee chair can i ask you a question
may i ask you a question please do
uh when you out of the room president
lloyd explained that in berlin at white
mountains they currently have the
capacity or the capability to support a
student getting satisfying all
baccalaureate requirements without ever
leaving berlin presumably through the
plymouth connection so my question for
you is uh i'm not sure if you if you
knew that
yes i did okay
so my question viewers
um
that
presumably does not satisfy your intent
is it correct say your intent is is to
have what's happening in berlin
uh ultimately be a berlin or white
mountains degree as opposed to a
plymouth degree is that where
was not any particular solution
my objective in proposing this
was to increase access to education for
all of these groups we've been talking
about
that was my primary purpose underlying
the mechanism toward which i
attempted to get us to discuss this
issue that we're talking about now this
very discussion
was to advocate that the community
colleges which already have the
authority to start a bachelor's program
but according i have letters here from
susan eward and others who said there
was a difficulty in the system in
getting agreement about how to deliver
that whether that was a mechanism and
that some people in the university board
advocated only doing it through the
university system they had a different
mindset on the issue
and so the bill to bring in the
community college was intended to have
to create this opportunity we are now
experiencing
to introduce the idea among serious
people with serious under experience and
understanding
is there something we need to change in
how we're doing this
what can we as a legislature do to
facilitate that process to make it
happen
to make it
need does it need funding here or
something there is there is there some
kind of mechanism that provides the
leverage that gets us from the condition
that you two were just talking about
into implementation
how to now having taught at two
different community college systems i
was at mass bay community college was my
first job in new england
i know that the difference in part is in
these community colleges are
student-centered universities quite
frankly are discipline centered
so there's a little turf fight whenever
you have gen ed oh our course has to be
in gen ed that always that's a reality
we all understand that
but it can get in the way
and so what i'm asking you to do is
think about then think is there
something maybe that we should be doing
to get rid of the turf part of it
to get rid of that and said what's the
objective if the objective is to get
these people education how do we do that
because people who want to sit on the
mission statement is the reason for
they're not doing it or doing it
don't want to take off move off that
down
that was plainly evident in the hearing
they held to which for me
to explain why the system couldn't do it
they couldn't do it because no one asked
them
now think about that think about that
for just a minute
if you're looking for an
academic driven
uh
economic development in the state
are you going to expect the people who
are least prepared
have leased education to come to you
with a concise statement of exactly what
they need to move the economy in new
hampshire
we're not dealing with a factory where
they train people to produce widgets
we're dealing with a world in which
exactly these badges you're talking
about
make the people who are the
quote-unquote workers
into at least mid-managers and it's only
after that as they get involved in the
mix of blending management and work in
community college of through community
college educated people now the workers
are mid-managers at least
because they're working to produce
software mechanisms that both are the
mechanism and the device in the end when
they finish
the created object
and so that's why i'm inviting this
discussion
and and doing and using this to have it
is because it's hard for discipline
centered people to talk about giving up
something they think
secures their job
it's a psychological thing
you don't ask somebody say gee why don't
we get something that does your job
better and then we won't need you that's
how their brain works
works but with me too
and so the the proposal for proposing
bachelor's degrees was a dramatic
decisive decision that would force the
issue
or at least force the discussion
so what we're having here is my
objective
mr subcommittee
chair follow up if i may oh please
uh first i want to note that typically
for upper level courses for a
baccalaureate degree you would have uh
folks with masters or or phds teaching
the upper level courses that that's an
issue
uh that maybe we can come back to my my
follow-up uh i just want to clarify i
brought this up earlier when you were in
the other committee room
the the language in 1530 specifically
refers to a bachelor's degree not
offered or available at any
institution university system so your
intent
is to show that it was possible that
there were things not covered
by the structure we had
now i'm i'm sensing that some folks on
the university system side might be
nervous or uncomfortable
thinking that if this were to move
forward that
that
community colleges who pursued a
baccalaureate option might
offer degrees or want to offer degrees
that are
already offered by the university system
so could you clarify that i think that's
a understandable concern on the
university side
but the language specifically seems to
say
that it is for some program not offered
is it is that your intent
my intent in selecting that example was
to show that there were things that the
university system will likely never
offer
for exactly the reasons that were
explained here they're expensive they
require a lot of equipment they don't
have anybody who teaches that they don't
have that expertise
now if they want to then go and get a
degree in
mechanics or in
economics or business or some
application of business that's fine but
that's add-on
that's not management of
whatever hydraulic systems etc etc what
i was envisioning was the degree that
would build management on top of that's
just an example of just
picking ideas out of the air
management a degree that would offer
somebody a bachelor's degree and not
only just a repair of something but the
whole management and down the train of
supply that we all hear about now and
all throughout that so that they would
have an option that was bigger than
because if they were going to grow into
something bigger than that their
business interests were going to grow
into managing your own business i grew
up in an advertising firm i was writing
it was that kind of thing where the job
grows and you grow with it
and so that's what i'm envisioning you
go in the military and suddenly you're
in motor transport and they want you to
be the officer and you don't know beans
about it
who would have been better
and that's why i thought about oh that's
a way of but they talk about it is we
want to produce jobs for new hampshire
wait a minute how about for people who
live in new hampshire
it's just like the people who say
science says science doesn't say
anything scientists say something
it's the people
and my focus is exactly on that
helping those people bridge a gap they
does that get at your questions or
representative
yeah thank you that that that's very
helpful thank you
anyone else
i'd like just to read you one statement
here
so you know that i didn't come into this
out of thin air
i've been talking with susan heward for
a very long time and after her
with chancellor here with us
susan wrote to me
after referencing my wife with whom she
used to work
at
where the heck was i'm trying to say it
now my mind went blank but anyway in the
state college system
i'm going to have to think about this
bill given the current ticklish
situation we have with the merger convic
conversation still being very active
as a system we have had this discussion
a number of times given there are at
least 19 states that permit community
colleges to be offered applied
baccalaureate degrees such as those you
has floated the idea of some specific
bachelor's degrees because there are no
completion programs in the state for
dental hygiene and radiology you will
not be surprised to hear there was
substantial pushback from the university
system and no i was not surprised that's
exactly what happened in minnesota when
i was there i was a university president
there
but the issues were the same
and then may i arrange a phone call we
i'd love to talk further about this with
you etc etc
this is not a new issue
it's just it's hard to get people to
want to talk about it because it means
change
universities have people teaching
courses who don't have doctorates too
and in some disciplines it's almost a
given particularly some of the technical
and finance things
those are taught by people with master's
degrees
even in universities
because that's where the specialization
is
i'm trying to get out of this this is
turf
i hate that word
it means you stop thinking before you
start
articulating the problem
that's why i said no no let's we're all
people here who value education in this
room
some of us have more degrees than the
others but you know after a while that
degree stuff gets to be
cumbersome
that's why
when i
wanted when i presented this bill and i
believe representative you made the
comment if i'm not mistaken what are you
saying about this bill or something to
that effect and i had to explain
this bill is a mechanism to look at
the new hampshire educational
opportunity equity act as much as i hate
that word equity
and i go right right into talking about
white mountain community college that's
there are people who
generally in in new hampshire people are
geographically disadvantaged
they can't get there from where they are
or there's no model on the hill near
their house to say come to the
university on hill
what they need is somebody with a
handout and a hand up
and that's what i'm saying is the role
it was argued if chancellor please
correct me if i'm mistaken on this but
it was argued within the in the bill
that presented to me that
in essence
we expect the communities to tell us
specifically what their needs are for a
particular business
tell us what kind of people you want us
to train
they may not even know
i spoke with a woman with a doctorate
and nursing really recently and she told
me nursing degrees are easier to obtain
in the commercial market than they are
in the educational market
my next door neighbor told me that he
got his job he's a marine gunnery
sergeant and we're talking shop over the
over the back fence and he said oh my
degree didn't my bachelor associates
degree didn't account for anything it's
the badges i had that got me the job
and they kept keep me employed i said
we're losing out if we make ourselves
inconsequential
we pretty soon don't exist at all
the role of the community college will
disappear because people think
they don't have anything to add to my
value to my marketability
that's why i'm saying we need to look to
the marketability yeah i grew up in
advertising i know marketing and i took
a business degree
and i'm an english major
whereas in ford uh you mentioned
specifically radiology or radiography
that was susan
okay oh that's from her okay sort of
mention uh to you
um maybe chancellor rubenstein or
someone someone would know the answer to
this i'm i'm curious
about that specific field of radiography
or radiology
if there is no
radiology
baccalaureate opportunity anywhere in
the state at this time i i don't know do
other states have baccalaureate degrees
in
radiology representative there a handful
of programs out there
when
former chancellor heward had raised that
issue we did actually look and as
president lloyd described one of the
first things we did was to try and find
out if there was employment demand that
would justify the degree doesn't mean a
student isn't interested in a bachelor's
degree
but we couldn't find a specific
employment market demand that would
justify the expense that would be
incurred at the time conversations did
ensue with the presidents of the usnh
institutions to see if any had an
interest in incurring the expense of
introducing those programs
no appetite for that but again the the
real issue is we couldn't find a a
benefit to students for offering that
program there are a handful of those
programs including dental hygiene that
lead to a bachelor's degree but but not
enough around the country to suggest a a
real market for it
thank you so it sounds like you've
already looked at that and uh okay
did again as president lloyd described
the starting point for this is it
valuable to students to employers value
will will it actually help somebody in
in delivering better care the the
bachelor's degree in nursing
the data support a better educated
workforce of nurses producing better
health care outcomes we couldn't find
similar compelling information
looking at the bachelor's degree for the
other two programs
sure you mentioned nursing i
specifically didn't i mentioned radio
radiology as opposed to nursing nursing
being a
plymouth as nursing now
so that would be clearly an area where
ccs and aids would conflict would
compete with u.s nh and so that that's
why i would not look at nursing i would
look at something like radiology which
you've already looked at it sounds like
but we of course offer nursing at all
seven of our colleges and and prepare in
a given year more than 200 nurses
entering new hampshire's workforce those
are students who will then typically go
on to complete a bachelor's degree some
point later in their careers but but we
offer the foundation for more than 200
some years as many as 230 or 250
new hampshire nurses
thank you representative ford um you
know
you you brought it up when you were um
when you were talking and and um
and catherine brought it up to the uh
the idea of credentials these stackable
credentials
and i i certainly i don't profess to
know a whole lot um about them other
than sort of anecdotally you know in my
experience um
of back in the day when i was uh running
a a
tech company
and um where where it was really clear
when we were looking to uh to hire
people you know we're looking for very
very specific skills
and
not necessarily
all the skills one would need to uh to
to become competent in in order to get
either a two-year or four-year degree
but a specific set of skills that you
might be able to
have a credential in after taking i
don't know let's say three or four
very specific classes and um
and you know i've been out of industry
now for uh for a handful of years so so
some of this has probably proceeded
um you know to uh you know beyond where
where where my familiarity uh was with
it but um i'm getting i sort of get the
sense from
from you know advisory board meetings
and talking with others in industry that
there's a tremendous growth in interest
not so much in uh in degree completion
but in um in these credentials that
build on on each other and um and
do they lead to a degree they might they
don't have to
and um
you know do the do they take
five years or six years or four years of
continuous study in order to
get to a
degree attainment um
um
you know
maybe maybe longer maybe never
um but the the value to the to the
employee
uh or the value to the student as being
an employee and a value to the employer
who may be very willing to um to you
know pay the
tuition costs for somebody to take three
classes and get the python credential or
whatever it happens to be
um i think is um is is really where
where where there there appears to be
a lot of demand or growing demand
thank you for asking that question and i
mean that quite so it's just a comment
well
there is a question in it because we
have to ask ourselves why would an
employer want to employ someone who is
always for the rest of his life going to
remain at the same level
because that's what you're talking about
you know by basically entry level
application level that person who's
going to stand at the i'll use the
figurative lathe
and work producing widgets
is going to be a good legit producer no
question and valuable is that kind of an
employee
but in an era in which one is likely to
move to becoming a supervisor
and then maybe even a manager all in the
same career time i would say that we're
doing them a disservice if we give them
half an education
we should give them we should sell them
an education an education that allows
them to expand with that education into
the roles that will be expected of them
as their career proceeds
and so i i don't want to use a majority
place like dead end but a career
stopping education that says you can
only go this far no farther
and i want to avoid that and can tell
talk to them about you're educating
yourself for a career not for a job
right now you need a job you need
incoming you need to feed somebody
whatever
but after that
there's a life
and i'm talking about educating them
toward an ambition toward an
understanding that their role will
increasingly become more and more
complex for which they need education
and that's why as i keep telling my
neighbor
said the bachelor's degree i mean
associated he did not get you the job
the badges got you the job
what about the next job
and that's the argument and he's my
neighbor he's also an ex-marine so you
know
how that goes
and so
representative if i might respond to
representative fluno's question
that
education
is what we do
both systems
how it's recorded has been changing
what used to be just degrees incl
increasingly includes certificates
increasingly includes badges and other
kinds of micro credentials but they're
not separate paths they're they're in
fact embedded
a student who completes a course
typically we say if you successfully
complete this course you'll understand
these things and you'll be able to do
these things well sometimes the ability
to understand do those things represents
what the badge is so that a student's
not just receiving a transcript with a
course name and a grade on it but is
actually receiving that credential that
an employer in an industry whether it's
novel network certification or whether
it's advanced care in an area of nursing
so that an employer can recognize the
specific competencies that are
associated with that but these things
are all stackable in the sense that that
they're integrated student may
accumulate credits toward a degree
satisfied degree requirements but also
has this other set of credentials along
the way in some cases those badges or
micro credentials may be standalone but
you put enough of them together
stackably they suddenly contribute
credits toward the degree so again
they're intended to be different
approaches for education to be delivered
and cap and captured and reflected on
transcripts that eventually have
portability and value for students
beyond just a particular job or a
representing be perfectly clear
um i understand president obama's bill
and your response
but i understand his request
for allowing baccalaureate degrees to be
obtained at a community college
your dialogue this afternoon is
indicated that currently is the stature
in a lobble if there is a need
i i i want to be very cautious and
although representative ladd is no
longer here i want to be very respectful
the fact that i don't assume what the
legislature enables us to do as
currently written
as it's currently written it says that
we are authorized to award the degrees
that are common for two-year
institutions and increasingly that has
become the case that bachelor's degrees
as we've heard earlier are are becoming
more the norm across the country
it's not our assumption that we can do
that without coming back here and our
interest in coming back here would only
be based on if we felt there was a need
for it
please thank you so
thank you and that was my point so in in
reality
um
this
request in this bill
has been satisfied
uh as we stand here today already
and that the delineation of specific
individual degrees are only uh generated
if there is a significant
amount of student enrollment and
interest
and i understand that and i understand
representative ford's philosophy you
need more than just specificity of a
piece but i also understand some people
are very happy with that and that's
where they want to be um but beyond that
in terms of the bill
you've met that
thank you thank you uh very much
thank you over there and thank you for
making specific what what i was trying
to explain in that first meeting when
you asked me the question about what are
you asking for or something of that
effect and uh
what i would like
this to result in is
are there changes that we should use my
bill
that you think
need to be made that would help you
accomplish your various missions and
that's that's the input i'm seeking the
bill sits right now just
waiting to be either pigeonholed or are
reformed and resubmitted
but i'm asking for your input and your
guidance on how we can better address
access
to a college education of all degree
levels
i don't want to talk to workers in the
future who tell me their associate's
degree has nothing to do with their
success in life
i come from a family that did not have
college education educations educations
were the way up
that's where my mindset is
so i want that education to be one that
meets its
expectations or meets our expectations
as citizens that's my goal and i don't
really care how it happens if it happens
in agreement and compliance by offering
a standalone program
i don't really care
that's not the point
the point is access
that's what i'm seeking anyone else
i'm done i just want to say i think
we're we're already
doing much of
um
what we're talking about well i quite
agree i didn't know some of it and yes
it's been educational for me very much
so i
i don't know that that
we need any statutory change to continue
the collaboration and build upon
the partnerships that we have i mean
maybe mark and i can think about that
but i don't know that we need statutory
change to
i guess maybe i didn't phrase that
correctly what i want you
want very much for you to do this is not
a mandate it's a question it's really a
hope
uh is that that collaboration will
continue to be explored and should you
require something that makes that
possible i think the example i gave was
paris who can't afford education you
can't afford health care is there a
mechanism we need to help create or
within the system
could that be done by the school systems
in some way i don't know these are naive
questions i'm asking i don't know the
answer
and so maybe that's something maybe the
student we're trying to address the
needs of now needs something different
than they needed in 1950 when the
community college system was
was created
and i'm just thinking we need to
continue to explore what are our
objectives and how best can we meet them
and that's what i'm inviting
and hoping for
does that answer your yeah i'm not into
hammering down this has to do produce
this degree
that's not the point that was the way to
and if you say there's nothing we need
right now i'd just leave it right there
in the folder
but if there is some it's there and
ready and i'm offering
us
because i know my my colleagues are
equally willing they're interested in
the same kinds of goals
but that if that if that meets the thing
we can end this meeting right now hold
on before you do before you go there
oliver okay
so
um
are there specific things
that the subcommittee would
i think were scheduled for another
meeting
monday on monday yeah
and uh in the afternoon again but are
there specific things that that that
this subcommittee would like to hear
about
um or like to learn about next week
what i had in mind was
should you wish to continue
was inviting people in the community who
are already engaged in self-generated
attempts to improve education in various
ways i'm thinking of one group that is
inviting is working on digital equity
another group that is working on
i see i think it's with
i don't trust my memory but manchester
high school maybe
and a west
high school
west high school was in favor of a gen
ed uh digital equity not digital uh
equitable education thing that was
changed to include fiscal
fluency
because they had a heart and a large
number of students who were not fiscal
they weren't banked because they didn't
trust banks from where they came from
it's a financial literacy all that whole
package and they wanted to include that
is that something that's part of this
that we might need to look at and say
well gee okay maybe if we triggered that
now we have people who are willing to
work in a bank in a school in high
school
and now go into bank going to community
college and get certain skills and maybe
they need more skills to become
quote-unquote a banker at whatever level
educationally driven economic
development
we have to figure out how to get
education into that formula just as you
were discussing the person that the
bachelor associates rightly did
absolutely nothing for his career
that's a warning symbol to me
we aren't keeping ourselves relevant
so maybe we have to go out and market it
the thing that occurred to me was
remember when when cars had starters on
the floor and you had to mess your shoes
up every time you started your cars
i'm that old
yeah and
all of a sudden they changed
i think they changed because of high
heels
women just just couldn't do that didn't
want to do it didn't want to mess up
their shoes but i mean okay it changed
the shape of our starters are done well
maybe we need to rethink
are we doing something that's keeping
people out of school or encouraging them
in school making that degree worthwhile
and that's what marketing does
mr chair
yes
follow up to representative lunos
so i i'm thinking here and i'm glad that
he asked that question because i'm
trying to understand this is an interim
study bill now
i shared a couple of subcommittees on
retain bills last fall in the in the
subcommittees we voted
recommendation to the full committee
so process-wise and i know there is
another meeting penciled in
i'm just trying to understand to follow
up on on his question um
do you see us taking a vote on the
or making a recommendation to the full
committee based on the statute that the
proposed statute we're looking at or
where do you see us going from here no i
would invite you to offer ways to modify
that
even including deleting the original
words
and reconfigure it to offer suggestions
or requirements
on how we can improve
access to higher education
follow-up would you be doing the report
to the committees that how this works no
i was thinking
my thoughts were whom can we get to come
here and tell us how it's needed where
it's needed and i was looking to each of
the people in this room
think you know someone that knows
something about this or is doing this in
ex high school or ex community college
or whatever come talk to us about what
we can do to make that work better
for you
as a community college as a university
as a whatever we want to see
some way by which we can say you came to
us and said we're doing this so we can
then respond and when they say what are
you doing for education we will respond
we have worked with these people maybe
only as a broker
but we'd have enabled them we've
supported them and we will fund whatever
attempt to fund whatever it is that we
think solves that need we're open to it
some of it's symbolic
some of it just says we're here and
we're ready to work with you
but some part of it is getting something
done back to uh
right that's what i'd see yesterday
oliver would you i assume then that
you'll work with the chair of the
committee to decide where this is going
to go
logistically
well in terms of coming back i was in
sec
expecting to ask you
should we invite people like that and do
you know people you want invited let me
personally
personally i think the systems are doing
a good job in terms of access
and i do not know any people who would
be added to the list to come in and talk
about
increased access into the system so i i
thank you representative ford i would
concur with um
representative ellison
i think your your point has been well
demonstrated to the
folks that here today representing the
community college and university system
i think listening to what we've heard
today they are constantly working
together trying to find alternatives to
youngsters to continue their education
albeit from the high school cte to the
community college community college to
four-year and a work field
having done some a little bit of work at
the college level i know after 12 years
in that situation i didn't like to waste
my time in a lot of meetings just
talking about someone else's thinking
i i would be hard-pressed to ask these
ladies and gentlemen to come back again
on their time i think they have if i'm
reading what i think i hear you say
if in their deliberations and their
communications amongst each other if
they find a need for our assistance
legislatively statutorily or financially
um that they would come back and ask
that i think that's what i'm hearing so
i'm not sure that asking uh continuing
this dialogue with them will be good use
of their time or or the communities
that's just one person speaking no i
hear what you're saying and i remember
the
the meeting that the chancellor and i
were
at
in which a representative of the
university board stood up and explained
to me that they could only build a
program in response to someone asking
for him that immediately followed the
conversation i had had with the only
student present
who nodded yes to everything i said
about their needing encouragement
and i kept saying he's not hearing that
student
he doesn't hear him at all i wasn't
offended i just noted that
and i went and spoke to the student
afterwards
but i also spoke with you and a number
of other people
but the idea was that i think they're
people we're not hearing we need to find
out how to hear them so
i would say for next week let me try to
get some people who can come in who've
been working with these people as well
as others and see if there's another
element one more meeting and then if we
don't have it we don't have anything to
pursue we're done
is that agreeable i mean is that
well i know but i can't drive you into
the corner the question is i don't want
a committee that doesn't want to engage
it
and you know i'm was pleased to have the
membership we have because these are
experiences dave's been on the board for
20 something years he said i hope i'm
not giving away any secrets
and so my sense is he's pretty committed
to that
and so
i would invite you at least one more
time
talk about it see is there something
more we can do it i'm open to any and
every
source
i don't think i have all the answers i
just have a question i can't quite
put the bid
are we doing enough what more could we
be doing
and that's what i'm asking you to say by
the next meeting and then we're probably
done you can bring another colleague
chair i've talked to several uh
just that sort of how can we better do
the coordination between schools better
than or do they need something to make
it work better
the issue of faculty not wanting to
travel to a distant campus how do we
address that we don't want to get in
negotiations we're not here as a
negotiating team
they've got collective bargaining for
that
i know that only too well
so
how do we do what we can do to foster
innovation
that's just
the
most concise
answer i can give to the question but i
don't want to not if someone keeps
telling me in the operation oh you got
to put somebody in charge of that
that's us
that's how i see it
see in what what's the next date
whoever's got the account
next monday okay
are we is that work you don't personally
have to appear if you send a rep that
we're into the idea generating business
we'll take if you send them we'll take
them
oh
you